president donald trump
has followed through on his threat to
veto the national defense
authorization act it's a massive i think
it's like 750 billion dollar bill
that essentially authorizes national
defense there's a couple interesting
things
in it most notably is a an amendment
that was added in july
that curtails the uh the president's
power uh
to invoke the insurrection act it would
require some kind of certification
through congress which
essentially defeats the purpose of the
insurrection act i guess but trump
vetoed it not because of this
he vetoed it because he said section 230
of the communications decency
act must be repealed now that would be a
huge mistake it would likely result in
you know what i don't i wonder if they
would ban this show they probably would
we probably banned
instantly you'd see the likes of you
know stephen crowder bench appear they'd
be gone overnight
because what section 30 does is it makes
it so that
youtube can't be sued for the things
said by
me ben shapiro or kyle kolinsky or
steven uh a crowd or anything like that
that you'd have to actually sue those
individuals for defamation if they
defamed you
if you get rid of section 230 then you
would just sue youtube for youtube you
know
is the one who published the content i
certainly think section 230 has its
problems when you perform
i don't think they're going to repeal it
mitch mcconnell is saying he's gonna
come back in on the 29th
and override trump which is a good sign
that
just before one of the most important
elections for the republican party
the republican party has more than
enough knives to place figuratively in
donald trump's back
which means probably trump supporters
aren't going to support the republican
party in that capacity but
we'll see we got a lot to talk about
we'll talk about uh nancy pelosi and his
covet stimulus package and stuff but we
got a we got a cool guest today you may
be familiar with him from his
congressional campaign
former congressional candidate joey
salads uh has joined us
i told you not to reference you like
that i told you i was going to do it
introduce yourself so yeah i'm joey
salads
i do pranks and political stuff i don't
know
there you go i don't feel like i'm
worthy to be on this show what do you
mean oh you're more than worthy yeah
what are you talking about like millions
of subscribers
i don't know it's all demonetized i
don't even post pranks anymore
i'm on youtube so i don't know you get
like tons and tons of views
dude you're playing it was pioneering
man it was i
i was pioneering that stuff but some
controversial for sure but uh then you
ran for office so now you're officially
a you know former congressional
candidate that's your that's your
official honorary title
but we can talk a lot about a lot of
stuff too it's interesting uh
i think you're probably one of the best
people to talk to about internet
censorship section 230.
not only are you like one of the when
did you start on youtube
i started on i've been doing youtube
since it came out yeah exactly that was
like
as a kid you know fourth grade was my
dream i want to be a youtuber that's
what i want to do
and you did it and i ended up doing it
yeah you got to do it every single day
kids if you're at home you want to be a
youtuber just do it every single day
and eventually if you make good stuff be
smart get better
right yeah so uh what we're going to
talk about this because the ndaa stuff
overlaps with the with censorship and
big tack and we'll be interested in
conversation of course ian's children
what up holmes
and i've got the super male vitality
that's michael's
michael thank you mr malice dr menace he
left it here it was so good
that i put some in my coffee oh does it
taste good yeah i tasted it it's sweet
interesting all right i liked it i don't
even know what it is you should have
some no i'm good
just in case you changed your mind all
right super
michael malus's super male vitility
infowars life it says on
the right it's really amazing how
supplements are like the go-to thing
that people sell what's up with that
you can't tell if they work i did one i
did one i think i did like two or three
ads for supplements a collagen
supplement yeah you can
that's good you know that's because i'm
like an old man and i ski i've been
taking so it's like
beetroot i've got like an array of like
10 different bottles of
fruit extracts and stuff and one is
beetroot extract it is
so good you will feel so much better
after two of those
until are you pitching a specific i will
let you know i got you a
christmas present is it beetroot
extruding city
all right uh lydia's hanging out i am
here pushing
all the buttons yeah that's right but uh
let's just uh let's jump in let's just
talk
let's let me just say some first we
weren't actually going to do a show
today this is interesting
yeah we were uh it's chris you know
christmas eve eve tomorrow's christmas
eve so
i'll tell i'll let you in look if i
could work every day through every
holiday i would
the problem is two things happen on
holidays like christmas eve and
christmas
nobody is working so very little happens
the politicians are at home they're not
talking about anything so there's no
movement but everybody's home
but nobody's watching this stuff so like
uh on holidays when people uh
for political content i can say at least
my views go down because people aren't
gonna turn on a podcast listen to
politics and hang out their family what
i do is
luckily i have so much evergreen content
throughout the years
i just repost christmas or seasonal
related content every single year so on
christmas i'll put up
like you know for those three four days
i'll just re-upload you know hey this
was kind of christmas related like a
package
that's a good idea i should do that i'll
go back from like a year ago to find
some news segment ideas
put it on flashback donald trump wins
the election yeah 2016.
we're gonna do a flashback video yeah it
was a good idea we're thinking about it
we're gonna be chilling
we got uh one story about a giant ball
of fire
in the sky in china crashed into the
earth um
i think this definitively proves it once
and for all aliens aliens yep yes
so we're good we're all right here we go
we all agree and uh we're just gonna
we're gonna hang out merry christmas
everybody we're chilling uh we weren't
really gonna do a show but then you know
joey's in town yeah he invited me on on
this day
yeah well i i got the day friday i'm
like that's christmas bro
that was a mistake that was a mistake i
didn't realize what day christmas was
and i was like maybe you can come this
day and then i was like oh wait just
come tomorrow dude
yeah so we got joey here but let's uh
let's let's let's uh let's talk some
news man
and uh this is this is big this is trump
trump vito's major defense bill citing
section 230 this is significant because
it's the authorization for national
defense it is a massive spending bill
it is a ridiculous spending bill the
most one of the most famous incidents uh
instances of the ndaa was when obama
signed into into law something called
the indefinite detention provision
which was included in it and allowed the
u.s government basically to like
rendition anyone anywhere like take you
and black bag you like you know like v
for vendetta where creedy puts the bag
over your head and then like
zips it and they drag you out that's
basically what it authorized so
you know seeing trump veto this i la
when i heard trump was gonna do when he
tweeted about it i started laughing but
let's read
techcrunch reports following through in
his previous threat
president trump has vetoed the 740
million okay million not billion
national defense authorization act a
major bill that allocates military funds
each year in tweets earlier this month
trump said he would sink the ndaa
if it wasn't altered to include language
terminating section 230
of the communications decency act an
essential and previously obscure
internet law
that the president has had in his
crosshairs for the better part of a year
quote your failure to terminate the very
dangerous
national security risk of section 230
will make our intelligence virtually
impossible to conduct
without everyone knowing what we are
doing at every step trump said in a
statement on the veto
it's not clear what the president meant
or what he was referring to and
criticizing the military funding bill as
a gift to china and russia
i just got to say i have no idea what he
means by that section 230 thing
and i think trump fundamentally
misunderstands what section 230 is
probably because his understanding of is
being filtered through
you know one or two people so you'll get
someone like me being like yo we need
section 230 reform section 230 is a
problem
someone will hear that and then be like
yeah section 230 is a problem and then
trump would be like it's a problem or
i'll get rid of it it's like no no no no
you get rid of it we're all banned we
don't want to do that so let's see they
say uh
trump tweeted about it the president
cited bipartisan calls for a section 230
repeal in his decision
in spite of the ndaa's overwhelming
bipartisan support so basically what's
going to happen now is mitch mcconnell
says december 29th
he's going to come back in override
trump's vetoes to make sure
every single trump supporter knows the
republican party hates
you hates your president i'm being a
little hyperbolic here
but yeah come on mitch mcconnell doesn't
like trump it was a really great comic i
don't know if you guys
follow uh george alex opposed he got his
paintings up on the walls he just put
one out where it's
it basically looks like the lion king i
guess trump is hanging from a cliff and
like reaching out
and then mitch mcconnell jams his
fingers into trump's hands and then
trump's like falling to his death
like the lion king and scar oh i want
that one yeah that's
so good man i'd love to get awesome but
uh look
if if section 230 goes our show's gone
the reason why there's probably
bipartisan calls to repeal section 230
is because the establishment hates us
they hate you they do now i'm not being
hyperbolic they hate you they hate me
they hate joey they hate ian
they especially hate lydia the
establishment she really doesn't know
what is it about lydia i think
i wanted posters because she's pushing
the buttons man that's true they're like
yeah so so look the establishment
democrats would love it if the
mainstream media were the only game in
town
and so you get rid of section 230 and
then overnight twitter facebook youtube
are flooded with lawsuits
many of them probably merit lists and
then it's going to be like we're done
ban
everybody we don't care you know you
know what youtube will do they would
love this
youtube's been trying to get rid of
everybody for a long time
and so they're doing something like uh i
don't know if you saw this joey with
what pornhub just did recently i did see
that banned all non-verified content
that's it if you're not a verified
channel you're going i used to have a
whole uh
photo pornhub channel yeah not like uh
bookmarked
like my favorite porn about it
yeah ten years worth of stuff i'm with
you
70 80 percent of it's gone i'm like oh
this has
been my library you know evergreen
content you know the livelihoods for
some people
i mean in all seriousness a lot of
people just lost their jobs and that
happened
i know there's a lot i know there's like
pornhub like creators
like youtube yeah yeah yeah yeah they'll
do like porn vlogs am i allowed to say
that
yes i don't know i don't probably not
demonetize whatever
yeah whatever merry christmas
but yeah but like it's it's like people
have their own channels and
you know they can make money i guess i
don't i don't i i uh my understanding is
now they're doing crypto because
mastercard and visa cut them off
but this is what's coming for everybody
they start with pornhub they always do
it this way too
because they know regular people won't
publicly fight for it
for the most part like nobody wants to
get them on on a pedestal and be like we
must protect our porn
yeah they're going to be like yeah they
go after the worst of society first
or just like the socially the fringes
and now i'll tell you what comes next
they did this thing we talked about a
little bit last week where
youtube got rid of verification for tons
of channels you remember that
yeah that they i remember they stripped
i i wonder if i'm still verified
well they there was a backlash and so
they said okay we're not gonna do that
we're gonna
do that i was actually one of the
approved channels where i got an email
saying you're all good we love you
you're verified
but eventually i think what's going to
happen is they're going to start set
so right now they already said we're
going to put ads on
content that isn't in the partner
program meaning yeah you upload videos
you're not the part like they'll make
money off you because youtube's been oh
they're losing hundreds of millions of
dollars a year oh yeah it's non-stop
i think what comes next is they're gonna
be like if you're not a verified
account in the partner program we are
going to stop promoting you in the
algorithm
and they're going to say you'll still be
or they'll say like we'll stop
recommending you as much
this is because you know we're trying to
improve quality for all of our creators
and make sure they can make money it'll
be great news for all of the bigger
creators who will now see bigger
viewership and things like that
and then they're going to start they're
going to tell they're going to start
getting rid of smaller channels
fringe channels people with the wrong
opinions yeah
and you know what it's it's two things
they're doing it one
for business reasons and then two
because they have bias
and the business reasons why they're
doing it is because the whole ad
pocalypse situations
where you know cnn or the late night
show they can post
whatever they want and they have reserve
ads on the back end where there was that
what does that mean reserve it so
well one first off they're i'm assuming
they're in the google preferred program
where they're getting the most exclusive
highest paying ads
and then also on the back end to fill
the extra ad slots
they have direct deals with companies
like coca-cola
to fill that extra space and they pay a
premium so
obviously youtube and google they get a
cut of that so that's one of the reasons
why they want to promote you know
traditional media there because they
have their own
set of ads you know from from direct
deals uh
so business-wise it makes sense
but that's not what youtube is and those
that content only gets views when they
feature it on the home page right nobody
and when you go to the front page of
youtube i'm sure all of you watching
have seen this
there is like the covid news bar and
everything's thumbs down to oblivion
it's like
10 20 thumbs up it's all just
obliterated
because nobody wants to watch that
garbage yep so youtube's trying to be
netflix
if we get rid of section 230 youtube is
going to start square dancing all the
ceos will be laughing they're going to
be like that's it
all the conservatives all the moderates
independents you're gone
msnbc guys you know progressives all
right we'll give you a pass
but if if we keep section 230 the track
we're on right now
is still really bad for independent
voices
smaller channels or anybody who's even
big and wants to challenge the system
because you could have a million subs
but you give a wrong opinion you're gone
yeah and it's what what these social
medias
the thing is i'm i'm more into the free
market where at first when this was an
issue like five years ago i was like ah
you know
they can do what they want their their
business you know they can operate
however they want but then over time
realizing
these social medias have a monopoly on
free speech on the internet
like the world wide web like if you make
your own website you can only
get generate traffic to your website is
if you promote it on twitter promote it
on youtube promote it on facebook
buy ads but buy a billboard actually
yeah billboard on sunset buy a billboard
or a commercial on the super bowl for a
million dollars yeah so
how much they cost something like that a
million dollars a minute or something
are they more probably way
way more than that yeah it's probably
like but like you could make a youtube
video it's
worth 10 times a commercial on the super
bowl i should i should buy a billboard
somewhere
well super bowl commercials are like
notoriously bad for no roi
like if you're a new company and you're
getting super bowl commercials like your
stock tanks because all the investors
yeah cause they know it's a bad
investment i think was pets.com is like
one of the most famous stories
i think it's bet one of those it was
like a pet type of website for adopting
animals
and they spent i think tens of millions
of dollars and you know six
months later a year later they're out of
business wow because they got
no return on that investment and like
the problem with billboards and
commercials is that there's no click
through you can't like see a commercial
and click the button to go to the
website whereas on twitter
you just click the link and you can
target exactly who you want to target
everybody who loves pets and animals
anyone who's
googling how to buy a dog you can target
them
google set it up that way too they set
up their algorithms to track what people
like so that you could use their service
to find people that like
what you're looking for yeah and they're
all sharing data so my girlfriend for
um for my birthday she got me an air
fryer
and she ordered it on amazon and then
we're watching tv we're watching
imd imbd tv and we're watching malcolm
in the middle
and an ad for that exact thing that she
bought pops on the tv
yeah the exact product happens that's
creepy yeah
they know you better than than you know
yourself yeah facebook knows when you
poop
i'm not kidding i always read an article
about it yeah because they
like people don't people don't realize
that there's things like
your favorite color correlates to other
things about you
you know what i mean so they could
someone could ask you a bunch of
questions that you think makes no sense
they'll be like what's your favorite
color what what's your favorite sport
you know where are you from and then
also they'll be like your favorite pasta
is you know
linguine pesto and you're like what how
did they make like a statistical
analysis people who like this
also like that right you know if you
like all three of these things you're
definitely liking this fourth i'll tell
you what
the uh if youtube does the verification
purge
it's gonna be really really good
business-wise
for channels like this so right now
i i remember when youtube did that
announcement about what was it what was
it called like the cp
something the child protection act cpu
and everyone's freaking out
all of the creators that do vlogs were
really worried
because they were like if we're deemed a
channel for children we don't get
access to targeted ads and our revenue
is going to drop like 80
and i started laughing and i'm like wow
this is great i do politics there's no
way you're gonna argue the stuffs for
kids and that means they're gonna we're
gonna get all those
those uh targeted ads and all that
everyone's gonna go more likely to us
than them
if youtube purges you know over time
from the partner program a bunch of
channels
that means and they start promoting more
verified and confirmed the viewers
consolidate around
the top one percentage what do they say
it's like 40 million
was it how many views per month is
youtube got a billion
billion views but if you got a billion
channels and there's a billion views
you know you get one view per channel so
get rid of all but 10 channels and now
everyone's getting they're kind of doing
it already
their select group of favorite creators
they're the only ones that have access
to the trending tab
they're getting you know google premium
ads you know they're on
all the vidcon billboards you know i
think google youtube owns
the vidcon event which is like the
creator type of thing
trash event by the way that was made by
um the vlog brothers
didn't they then they inceptualize yeah
that was uh the greens right yeah yeah
john
those guys hank and john hank hank yeah
those two they went they went kind of
crazy
it's really it's really it's really
weird how the the social media drift
created this class of people who were
trying to out left each other that's so
weird it's like
bro remember where jon stewart used to
be that's where we were all at
but you guys kept trying to one-up each
other i guess to like prove your value
or virtue
yeah that's further and further left
every single day that's
how they make themselves feel morally
superior
so they're morally superior to you
because they support black lives matter
they care about black people you don't
well but i think like you know like the
vlog brothers
were doing it because it was popular
marketing
so you know you get social media and all
of a sudden the craziest activists are
screaming at their lungs
and then you're like how do i get
attention wow everybody's talking about
this i should talk about this
too so you look it makes sense man
if you're trying to if you're in the
business of attention
where this is what we are this you know
like the goal of this show
what not directly is to keep people
watching it as long as possible
the goal of youtube facebook and twitter
is to keep you looking at that screen on
their website as long as possible it's
the attention economy
and then as we do we sell ads so for
for us it makes sense to talk about
important political news
and you know talk about what we believe
in and stuff and naturally that
generates an audience of like-minded
people
what they're doing is the inverse they
see a big audience of crazy far leftists
and they think
that's my path to make money now it's
funny as the leftists accuse
like us of doing that grifting of like
they're like tim poole used to be like
super left and now he's conservative or
whatever and it's like well first of all
like opinions change
like earlier this year i was not pro i
was not 2a
like hardcore as i am now now i'm like
very much to a it's between
you kind of drifting a little bit more
right and then also the
the spectrum of the left shift also
shifting but i actually moved uh further
left
actually yeah so i you know my political
compass test i'm actually
further left libertarian i used to be
like pretty liberal now it's like down
and like more left libertarian
but uh leftists are not a lot of a lot
of conservatives don't get this
the actual economic left libertarian
they are pro-gun
they're not anti-gun it's it's the it's
the establishment elites the
authoritarian
groups that are pro-gun even the
authoritarian communist types are
pro-gun
how are they going to have the
revolution yeah so they're definitely
pro-gun
they're very there's like as a reddit
page for socialist
gun rights and stuff like that so anyway
but what happens is
you have people like the vlog brothers
who aren't you know look
i i'll leave them out of this but i'll
wrap them in the bigger picture
celebrity
what are celebrities for their marketing
that's it
they're people they are marketing the
reason why they put brad pitt in the
movies because they put brad pitt's name
on it you go see the movie
so the same thing with these youtubers
the goal is
they want to generate as much attention
as possible when they see
everyone's clamoring about social
justice they're like oh i can do that
too i can do that too
the right has that you know there are
certainly people who are like i've
decided to support this or that but it's
going to make me money
but i think that's a tendency of the
left more so so it's like it's
disproportionate you have more leftists
or fake leftists who pretend to be left
doing that then you have people
supporting trump the people who support
trump
tend to really support the guy yeah and
it's
when trump you know supposedly lost the
election
i was just getting flooded with people
saying give it up already stop crying
you cry baby trump lost get over it i'm
like wait first off the election's not
over trump didn't concede whatever is
happening is happening
um but i'm like they don't understand
the difference between having a passion
for the country a passion for actually
liking the president
they don't understand the difference
between having a passion and then
yelling and screaming and crying at the
sky
you know when trump lost election night
uh we you know we took what's the legal
process let's investigate let's do this
let's do that when the democrats lost in
2016 it was just screaming
and yelling at the sky they did their
the other celebrity videos where they
were like the electors you
must have overcharmed you must be faith
listen to phi
right now in iowa there's a woman her
name is rita hart she lost by
six votes guess what she's doing
suing to overturn the results arguing
that they should reinstate
22 mail in bouts that were disqualified
because then she wins
yeah and i say okay well you have the
legal right to do it by all means it's
funny though
i mean it's when these elections are
that close even trump you know
lost by you know 10 000 votes in some
states states with you know
3 million 4 million in population 10 000
votes
nothing comparatively to the pocket well
you know trump only won 2016 by like 77
000 votes
yeah he got a big electoral victory but
there were three states where he only
got like
point one percent like really you know
thin margins but it's funny to see
this dem the democrats are like when
we're you know when we lose it's okay
for us to overturn the results
and i don't see any of these news
outlets saying this is shaking
confidence in our elections and it's
evil and wrong now they're in support of
it
the person who's filing the suit on her
bf or like who's working with a lawyer
is one of the lead critics of trump in
his legal effort to overturn the results
so it's like this guy goes on twitter
all day and he's like trump is you know
what he's doing is wrong and he's gonna
lose it's ridiculous how dare he and
then i'm gonna file the exact same
lawsuit for my person
don't look over here everybody the left
their their ideology is like a sliding
scale there's no consistency it's like
all about what benefits
them at that particular moment at that
point in time right
where one day the left can be on twitter
praising the constitution because
something went their way
and then the next day say with the
constitution was founded by a bunch of
racists right right right and now we
need to destroy it so wait yesterday you
just love the constitution because it
helps you
now you want to worse of course i was
thinking that power
just kind of in general the power they
say power corrupts people and that we
this social media uh view count
is like a source of power when you have
the ability to go click a button and
tell someone something and a thousand
people here you say it
that people are getting slowly driven
insane and then when they get the likes
and they're like oh when i did that
complaint it got a bunch more likes from
those creeps
and then they get even crazier and so
you've got people in politics going
crazy
that we call them the left or the people
in social media like brad not brad pitts
crazy but these cult
you know these these youtubers that
ended up like the vlog
yeah and it happens on both sides too i
mean it happened
with me at points on twitter it's like
okay let me keep saying this and it
keeps me
more and more likes or let me make
videos on this and just
push the edge it drove me to insanity in
the early days of youtube i thought the
only reason people looked at me was
because i was crazy like i would smoke
weed and talk about the craziest stuff
people like this guy's insane this guy's
insane but those videos would get the
most
views exactly and so i kept doing it and
tried to out insane myself and i was
getting depressed and
it drove me insane i almost killed
myself it was that's why i went
i i'm so controversial online with my
pranks because
the algorithms were rewarding being
controversial being offensive
you know doing crazy crazy just crazy
and crazy and you get to that point
where you're realizing oh wow
i took it kind of far and then you kind
of take that step back
there's people who who uh don't realize
they get they get caught in the
algorithmic loop
and then they start producing more and
more and more i think people need to
need to recognize what this is but i
will tell you something
these big tech companies will ban the
right so the wall is set
right so if you're if you're on the
right and you start seeing you'll tweet
something you'll get more likes
so you tweet more of it you go crazy you
get more followers you get more shares
then twitter bans you you went too far
they say
we see you go too far you should have
stopped it's too bad you're out
on the left you can literally call for
riots and terrorism and violence
and they won't remove it yeah listen to
this i when i got banned on twitter i
made another account called not joey
salads whatever
and it was not me somebody else was
running it and for me
and i did that i actually i went through
three different twitter accounts
so that account in particular got banned
because i said i replied to the la mayor
saying
but sure just let them burn the city
down sarcastically because he was
talking about black lives matter or
whatnot yeah and i got banned for
inciting violence
immediately the very next day
was when they were calling for riots oh
because uh
rbj ginsburg died very next day was
trending
burn it down for whatever of course of
course man and i i got banned for being
sarcastic
when i was on the joe rogan show with
the people from twitter
we pulled up a tweet that had been up
for months
that was calling like those of us i
think the tweet itself was a felony
and i was like why is that tweet still
there and they're like uh
i don't know oh we can't monitor every
single tweet
and i was like but you could see that
replies to it were banned yeah so you
had this tweet from an antifa account
calling for overt violence instructing
people to commit violent you know
felonious acts and it was fine
below it was like this tweet has been
removed for violation of policy this is
remove remove remove removed yeah
and so when they were like well you know
people have to report these things for
us to notice and i was like
the replies are banned clearly people
are reporting this like crazy
and each other yeah i'm telling you
right now they all these social medias
if they don't they're stupid they
definitely have
certain key phrase algorithms that
determine if you tweet
saying i want you to burn whatever down
whatever they know in their algorithm
and i know tick tock does this a lot if
they scan the video and they notice
something that's questionable
they'll actually put the video on hold
send it to a review
to determine okay was this a violation
okay it wasn't and then it gets cleared
so you i mean you know what you know
what tic toc used to do they were
it was really clever if if on uh uh
youtube somebody is getting cyberbullied
youtube will ban the bullies
on tick tock if somebody was getting
cyberbullied they'd ban the victim
because think about it makes a lot of
sense if you don't want bullying on your
platform
do you ban the 300 bullies or the one
victim
well if you want your user numbers to be
inflated
you don't want to ban 300 people can't
do that ban the victim yeah
now the bullying is gone congratulations
only beautiful people to be on our
platform yeah tick tock's done a lot of
sketchy stuff when it comes to you know
favoring beautiful people yeah algorithm
it's it's weird because when i'm on
tick-tock
i even though it's owned by china or
in bed with china yes it's it's still
i think more free speech than you know
the other platforms
which is i think i think uh without
getting too specific some of these
social social uh networks are fake
fake likes fake views yeah i remember
what facebook was doing with inflating
their uh view counts by like 90 percent
remember that yeah yeah because i think
did they get sued i thought they had sue
like a bunch of
man advertisers i think got really mad
what happened yeah dude so
facebook would you you'd play a video
and it would say you had a hundred
thousand views
when you actually only had like ten
thousand
now they counted because i don't know if
they were actually making
it fake but you know when you post a
video on or something on facebook like
you would scroll past it
yeah that counts so your videos will
sometimes be like a hundred thousand
reach
twenty thousand views so it was on a
hundred thousand people seen it as they
were
an impression but they didn't actually
watch it but now it only counts if you
watch for three seconds or more
then is that like a legal thing is there
like a lot longer that has to be
threesome no but what was happening was
people were selling ads and facebook was
selling ads and then
facebook would be like oh look a million
views congratulations that'll be you
know x amount of dollars
but then people found out wait a minute
those views aren't real because they
just scrolled past it and didn't
actually
watch it in any capacity so dude this
was facebook destroying the news
industry
no joke i i there are some companies i
know that were very prominent mainstream
networks that have gone bankrupt or
shuttered the divisions that they had
set up
there are some companies that would uh
do youtube videos and they had
millions of subscribers combined maybe
like 500 000 here a million here maybe
you know
1.2 million and i had a meeting
in san francisco with some of these
these companies because i was working
for a fusion at the time
and they were telling me how facebook
was the key
facebook's where it's at you don't
understand and i said bro what do you
mean i understand
youtube is where it's at and they're
like no no no man like we put up a video
on youtube we'll get like a hundred
thousand views on facebook we get like
10 million
and i was like you those aren't real
dude there's no way
you put up your dumb video and got 10
million views
the good thing about facebook is
everybody has a profile
with hundreds of friends right so
someone could easily share
youtube you've got to get the other one
but check it out i was right and so what
these guys are telling me i remember i
was at a lunch in san francisco
it was like three the three video heads
of like three different digital
production companies that were on social
media
with youtube being their principal place
for for production
and i was i was like youtube all the way
man i was like i can see the community i
can see the interaction i can see the
excitement
i can see the virality on facebook it's
just like one day you put the video then
boop it's got 10 million views and i'm
like where'd that come from yeah and
they said you're wrong bro
the industry is changing you don't want
to be like blockbuster video you want to
be like netflix
and i said no it's smoke and mirrors
these guys are out of jobs yeah
those divisions all shut down because
when they were putting in like they have
like a budget for like a million bucks
or whatever for their production for the
year
and these are big these are big
companies and then when they said shift
the
production to favor facebook and then
facebook didn't turn anything back for
them
didn't give a return they just fizzled
that ran out of money and then their
bosses were like we just lost a million
bucks made nothing get out you're fine
like the retention time difference
between facebook and youtube i can put
up a video on facebook
30 to 50 second retention time same
video on youtube
you know six seven minutes exactly
that's the difference in facebook right
now they're making that algorithm push
into the watch tab they made a whole
nother section on facebook now i guess
they're trying to kind of compete with
youtube
and they're favoring the higher
retention content that kind of keep you
on
the phone you know they want you to turn
the phone sideways and watch your piece
of content
with facebook you can slide down you see
it you click it but then there's this
like sliding mentality you're in so you
keep going whereas youtube you have to
click a
button you can go there there's nowhere
to slide to unless you want to read the
comments
yeah and you're invested you're actively
engaging and clicking on a piece of
drugs it's like the worst drug of our
time yeah do you so you're off twitter
now
off twitter and uh how's that been oh my
gosh my mental health
is so much better you real like twitter
is
once you get off twitter you realize
that's not reality that's not the world
uh it's been harder to keep up on
politics and what's going on like i used
to know everything at all the times now
you know
i know nothing about what happened today
absolutely not trump did it backflip
i
yeah twitter is a disaster it's an
addiction
and they know that the likes and shares
and retweets those numbers
are what drive people to keep doing it
it's making the country go insane
they know it they don't care and they're
trying because they make money off
they're trying to keep you going back
too so a lot of social media have a
theory
that if you're not like going on the
platform like they'll kind of send a
little engagement your way
to keep you opening the app up again
keep you engaged and looking
right you know you have the
notifications on like oh i got a new
follower you click on it now
exactly i think in the beginning of
youtube i don't know how it was for you
guys but
for me it was i wanted to make videos
and tell my friends about this book i
read
and myspace wasn't fast enough so i
would make it wasn't about how many
people saw it it was
did eric see it youtube had friends yeah
i wanted to share my
and then people could make video
responses and you had these little
communities of people
and now that it's like i don't know if
they really want to just get people off
the platform these non-verified people
because they're taking up too much
bandwidth and they're too much of a
liability
yeah especially if 230 goes down then
they're really alive exactly and
and they want more like a tv station
like netflix where yes
but we need these these some website
where a bunch of like any kid
can start making youtube videos and talk
to another guy that's making
videos that doesn't have to be youtube
videos i've just got that phrase stuck
in my head from
from you 2006. youtube employees have
told me and this is years ago
they want to be netflix so
in the early days of youtube look at the
market cap of netflix
right exactly 200 and 700 youtube's
tried doing originals
disney's trying to be netflix they're
doing a good job it's got to be a
headache to deal with all the errant
people that are saying like burn it like
they say crazy stuff then you're you're
not responsible but if you don't do
anything and it's illegal then you
become responsible no
well if someone puts illegal content on
youtube the it's youtube's job to take
it down or aren't they responsible for
hosting illegal content
section 230 protects them if it's
illegal they're not liable
for content posted by individuals
so they will ban everybody if 230
gets repealed it'll be the end of the
internet as well
what if the plan is to repeal it and
replace it immediately with something
else that will never happen
the democrats right now are probably
sitting in a room with republi
the democrat republican establishment
are sitting in a room together and
because this is a family-friendly show i
will say they're sitting in a circle all
patting each other on the back
going like yes yes this is great you
know we're having time they're all
shaking hands
a circle of of of jerks by fiving each
other what a bunch of jokes and
when right now they're probably going oh
no
trump oh jeez you want us to repeal
section 235
oh man i guess we have to well listen it
is what if
that is actually a good thing what are
you doing in 230
what if because they mass ban people
like me you
and the little guy then now it forces us
to go to an alternative platform or to
start our own platforms no you know what
you do
youtube is the platform the place to be
if you want to make
long form video content and that's the
only place you can go to get views
but now what happens if the you of the
youtube gets completely taken out
now now oh i guess i'll try rumble or
netflix exists
but netflix doesn't allow anyone to post
they approve
so what would end up happening is like
roku the otts
they just allow anything right they
allow people yeah okay so so here's
here's my bet
you know what i'm not gonna i've had
i've had people telling me i'm wrong
several times
they super chat they're like you're
wrong tim 230s got to go you don't get
it i'm like all right dude i know
exactly what's going to happen if 230
goes
i am going to make 10 times as much
money it's going to be great for me and
it's going to be bad for humanity and
liberty and freedom
but if people want it if trump's saying
it and trump supporters are for it
okay i guess i'll just sit back and take
the extra money because let me let me
say what's going to happen
there i'm not going to be banned if if
230 goes
i'm going to be one of their preferred
verified accounts or whatever
they like the milk toast you know
harmless timpool or whatever
he's just edgy enough but not not edgy
enough to get smears and cause cause any
trouble
because i'm not too you know far enough
in either direction so it works for them
that people watch these shows and that
they're controversial a little bit and
they actually monetize their alex jones
episode so they're like this is okay
we're okay with this
so if you get rid of touching 230
youtube's gonna go we got it baby we
finally got what we needed the excuse to
ban all these people without causing
controversy and we can blame trump for
it it's great
so who are we keeping we're gonna pick
500 channels to keep
youtube is now officially netflix this
is fantastic our bandwidth costs are
going to drop but our audience
stays the same if you you get rid of
section 230 and youtube
bans all of the non-preferred accounts
they probably sign a contract or
something about liability and whatever
then what you're left with is youtube
still gets the billion views or whatever
per month whatever the number is
probably more than that probably 100
billion or something they keep that
it'll go down a little bit because some
channels and some creators will be gone
and they'll go to other platforms
but people will still go to youtube out
of habit and now there's only a small
handful of channels to recommend
so guess what the existing channels are
going to go
through the room what platform because
that platform could get taken down too
i think yeah exactly let me tell you
this yeah everyone's saying rumble right
now like i'll go to rumble go to rumble
okay just like any of these other
platforms i'm just going to start
counting the days
until nbc the wall street journal new
york times published a story about
you know the the neo-nazi website rumble
and all the other garbage get thrown in
there and then what happens is
all they need is an excuse is one
article
that says it and then you'll get you'll
get google going like we will no longer
you know serve the you know the dns or
whatever what is that google
anti-defamation
they go hard people for that stuff yeah
yeah google sees the dns i think it was
the daily stormer
like literally just seized their their
domain so you couldn't go to it it was
crazy
like that's authoritarian beyond
recognition i'm just obviously
spitballing here
i could be completely wrong but let's
just say you have a billion
watch minutes going to youtube every day
to watch independent creators
and that's what you want to watch as we
were saying before whenever cnn is
recommended just
spammed with dislikes i'm sure their
retention times dirt low as well
but obviously they want to work to kind
of replace cable and tv that's why they
have youtube tv they tried youtube
premium
and they tried original shows all those
original shows have been a major flop
even the influencer one no
uh uh visualized coprice well that was
awesome good because it was on netflix
well no no i did really well on youtube
that was then they saw me one then i
sold it
yeah that was the only one that people
watched um i don't know what the numbers
were on that
if it's even comparable to how much it
got on netflix i never watched it on
youtube i watched it on netflix it was
great
youtube youtube works on meritocracy so
there's it's a combination of
algorithmic promotion for videos that do
well and
the the hands-off approach from youtube
when youtube tried to do originals yeah
it
mostly did not work a lot of the shows
were just trash
so what they do is what works for them
let people make content
and then when they identify content
that's doing well and is brand safe and
advertiser friendly
they promote in the algorithm but i'll
tell you this
how many let me ask you if you if what
do you think the average amount
of recommended views to
like uh subscriber views you know what i
mean like
yeah the amount the i'll just i'll just
say because it's probably hard to make
an analogy or a question out of it
the amount of people who watch this
content who
aren't subscribed i'm not subscribed to
you i watch you every day right
i have 10 accounts that's why i don't
know what account i'm on i just
subscribe with all of them yeah
no no maybe not because you don't want
to inflate the subscriber count because
then if the view to subscribers is is
racist and they punish you for it
but so so here's what happens it's like
depending on the video it could be
between 60
and 70 not subscribed that means
youtube's recommending the video
so you go to youtube.com and then my
video appears and you click it and you
watch it
and youtube keeps serving it people
because subscriber counts really don't
matter anymore
i mean we do this show we have uh about
nine almost 900 000 subs on this on this
channel
and we get like we're averaging like
half a million per podcast
episode so that means like more than
uh you know it's like 60 percent of the
audience watches you know every day or
whatever
that's great or you can say that most
people watch uh you know a couple times
a week and the way like
the algorithm works to my understanding
is
uh because i know people who have zero
growth on youtube
but they'll have a million subs and
every video they post gets a quarter
million and a half million views but
they don't have any growth
because what youtube sees okay this
piece it's mostly vlog
content this vlog is getting very high
retention time with its subscriber base
so they'll push it out to more of the
subscribers and then they do kind of
testing and the algorithm for some like
look-alike audiences
and then they check the retention time
from those algorithmic viewers
and then usually those algorithms don't
come back good because it's the fans
that want that content and they pull it
back and it doesn't get the expanded
growth
but it has a high percentage of watch
time from
subscribers my page is the complete
opposite my prank page
where i'll get like 10 of my subs
watching and then like randomly like
two three months later i'll have a video
pop off with like five million views
yeah because it's just like the
algorithm since it's all evergreen the
algorithm be like okay well this content
does good
with random people clicking on it well
it'll find that audience it'll
fall so here's what i'm saying if
you get rid of the independent creators
they're not going to leave youtube
most views come from people who are told
what to watch
no joke yeah now there's a it's a mix
between the interests of the individual
and what youtube recommends
if youtube if there's somebody who likes
watching you know videos titled
democrats are awful
and they send a video saying democrats
are great they're gonna be i ain't
clicking that
you know and so it just it gets ignored
so there's a balance there
youtube would probably lose a decent
amount of their users if they did if
they banned everybody
and if section 230 got repealed but most
of the people would probably stay
then the activists would just target
other social networks and yeah there are
two types of people that use youtube
maybe three there's one the group of
people that want to see independent
creators and the group that just goes to
youtube to
just they probably don't even have
accounts that are just like oh i'm gonna
just google this
look it up or i remember watching this
funny viral video let me look it up and
show my friends or they're just typing
in funny cats you know yeah the casual
users maybe they're going on to see the
news
um they're like less engaged but those
types of people youtube is the go-to
so you can read you get researching 230
and i'll be
i'll be doing great yeah well in the
short term
but i mean i don't think any of us will
be doing well i don't know actually bro
you know what is money you know much
money like
sean hannity gets and like what his
viewer viewership is from his youtube
stuff
so he his his viewership i think was at
like you know four or five million a
night at its peak and then
people abandoned fox but even without
him getting four or five million a night
and then you include youtube when so i
recently cut down the amount of segments
i was producing
but i was getting like three three and a
half million a day sean hannity was
getting
you know four or five million the
problem is you would be like the golden
child and your ad revenue will go up but
you'd be stuck
under their uh their terms of service
still
which could get more strict the
difference between i guess traditional
media hosts and new media hosts is
nutritional media
the ad rates pay way higher that's what
youtube wants
though yeah and they play way more ads
mainly because there's no skipping
around there's no jump i guess you could
change channels but if you're watching
sun hannity and the
commercials start yeah you get like five
commercials exactly
minutes go by yeah on the internet
people do not have the patience
stupid ad i'll watch another video yeah
maybe we need our own network each
individual has their own network where
they can post all their videos so you
don't have to worry about 230
of anyone else's content and then you
can respond other content through like
an rss where you can see if they
responded to one of yours
i don't know if you could watch your
videos on my network because that might
make me it's kind of like what roku is
doing
so i worked i just signed up with a
company and they're like hey we want to
put your
prank content into its own channel on
the roku devices i'm like yeah just go
ahead do it
and like they made a channel joey salads
channel they link it with like an rss
feed
so whenever i post it automatically gets
posted into that is roku
responsible for your content under 230 i
wouldn't know about any of that that's
interesting
if they weren't that'd be really cool if
just cool because it comes off like an
actual shot so i was telling you to do
it because it go
people watch that stuff on the tv
retention times higher the ad rate cpm
is higher
i'm sure tons of view viewerships would
love to watch your podcast and just
click it on the tv you know man
i could do a million things to make my
business distributor
we don't do any ad reads you know like
people listen to this podcast and we
have
no ad reads at all like for for for
instance we don't talk about super male
vitality
yeah alex from an infrared should get a
kickback
give me some money because we mentioned
your um that's right how many did you
sell alex
yeah yeah we want to cut numbers no but
uh like almost every single podcast they
open the show with some kind of ad so
i'm talking to people about doing some
kind of ads because i'm like
we're not being particularly efficient
with how we do things we can't just turn
the cameras on and just hang out
you know we probably do a lot better job
but you know what man
times are getting crazy it's christmas
we're chilling
yeah i'm into the roku so this roku
thing sounds pretty uh promising that's
gonna
i feel like that's gonna be the new wave
of next year you're gonna see a lot of
creators
so the earlier you get now that i'm
saying it on such a big show i bet you
ever
ever like created how do i sign up
people need to realize you know i think
there's a lot of people who look for
quick gimmicks to try and get big quick
they look at vine the original frozen
family with vine
man how many people remember what vine
was oh yeah they're huge
did you start on vine yeah that's how i
got my big break we gotta see look at
that
flying fine i can't zoom in oh when they
destroyed it well i did like a series
called like it's bash in time
yeah you got started on vinyl then i got
yeah that's how i got my big break
then i got facebook and youtube hey if
any of you
reps are watching re-monetize my pages
or all some exercises
what happens if they change their logo
and then you got like what's that
company it's like youtube oh that's
right
it's like imaginative for youtube i was
gonna get the instagram one and then
like i didn't end up getting it
and then like yeah then like two weeks
later they did a new instagram logo so
you were big on youtube and then you
started doing vine you were huge on
youtube in like 2010 right 11 or
something
i did youtube since i was a kid never
got any views
you know hundreds maybe a thousand views
if i was looking
then i took like a two year hiatus
because i was like ah this is not
working out this is not going to be a
career let me go to school
went to college for like a year failed
everything but during that time
i downloaded vine because an
ex-girlfriend of mine made me download
it
because she was like recording videos of
me like this is such a stupid app six
seconds like how can you
yeah download it end up making a bunch
of videos ended up going viral got you
know a million followers on there like
damn vine's gonna go under i'm like i
saw how the market was going
it's all about like retention time and
this must have been like 2011 or
whatever
and then i started moving all my
audience to youtube stopped posting on
vine
and then a year later i went out of
business how could you tell them got
bought by
twitter yeah and then they were
basically like this is
your periscope's gone right oh oh really
yeah periscopes that just went on
when wow uh i saw something about i
don't know exactly what's going on geez
too much bandwidth cost
well no because what twitter does is
they buy a company and then once people
are used to using it on the twitter app
they
they ax the other company they just
mailed them into twitter
the competition what yeah buy and
destroy it's called hostile takeovers
vine was unique because it was the first
like app to have video format on
and then yeah you know instagram came
out with it and yeah because instagram
was just photos since the bandwidth on
phones also started to increase you know
youtube became more accessible on
on the apps you know so it's just you
know fine was like
the first of its time and just never
innovated past that point
and they didn't do that by twitter and
then yeah that was the biggest
they never got ads they sold the company
instead yeah i was hearing stories that
they were gonna put an ad
program in place but then like a bunch
of influencers
were like spreading the word and then
everybody wanted a piece of the cut and
then they just can't
hyperinflated their value and sold
probably i think a thousand times
i think influencer value is
it's tough because i think influencer
value is
overrated but at the same time it is
that powerful yeah
money can't buy it's the value of
communication the thing is like
i use ninja for example he was the uh
guy yeah he was the biggest twitch
streamer
he was all over he was you know favored
so they put a fortnight right yeah for
fortnight
remember when he did the dance on new
year's and no one knew who he was yeah
maybe that's why you guys might know
where know him he did the the floss
dance
in in times square in new york nobody
there knew who he was i think they might
have knew who he was
no complaint man his audience is 12 year
olds that's true
but i i gotta i have a i have a friend
who's like uh he's
he was in a band that was like decently
famous and toured around and when i met
him
i was at his there's this venue for like
you know it's a big venue which
called the metro some band was playing
everyone there was like in their 20s and
30s
and i saw and i was like whoa dude
aren't you so and so he's like yeah i
was like wow man nice to meet you i'm a
fan
he's like cool man and i was like
anybody here recognize you and he goes
how's everybody here
are they over 18 no probably not and i
laughed and i was like what'd it say
about me
yeah but yeah like his audience wasn't
there yeah back was saying about ninja
is
mixer bought him for like tens of
millions of dollars whatever they paid
him
i think some people were saying was
close to 100 million that's microsoft
right
yeah microsoft bought mixer mixer what
ninja then they started getting other
influencers too
but they thought you know ninja the
biggest twitch streamer we're gonna get
him on mixer and that's gonna help out
mixer
his viewership went from hundreds of
thousands of live viewers to like
a thousand two thousand oh yeah not at
first when he first went on it was big
numbers
and then it just died off because
influencers
many influencers are only as strong as
the platform
they're on yeah dude and i saw that same
exact thing happen with joe rogan
i i listen to jeroboam but only on
youtube i'll watch his viral clips i'll
listen to it here and there maybe then
i'll go over to a full show but it's
always on youtube
you know i haven't been to spotify yet
yeah it's kind of like i don't want to
i don't do it like i'm just like angry
that he went to spotify still but i
don't i just i got no beef hey good for
him i i mean i would take the bag too
i mean yeah that's a lot of money but
it's it's almost it's it's i wonder
we talked about before it's almost like
a retirement you know yes that should be
disregarded because i know joey's a
friend but you know
when someone offers that much money oh
yeah i'm sure joe he's a good
businessman
exactly next level but he probably knew
exactly what it meant by going exclusive
with spotify
and there was a big backlash where
people were commenting
so his like his main youtube channel has
become a click has become a clip channel
i guess a clip channel is nothing now i
have no idea
that's million that's 10 million
subscribers and he recently got the
diamond award on youtube
all those subscribers subscribed to
watch the long form show not the clips
and so now
there's comments of people who are like
i don't even watch anymore but here's
you got to realize too by going to
spotify he lost the comment section
yeah so people are having conversations
that's gone
and the discoverability on youtube was
what's really driving the traffic i mean
spotify is its own
platform but it's not something really
people go there to discover stuff
but if you but the good news is for him
now is that you know you go open up
spotify podcasts and joe rogan
experience yeah right there
100 million dollars and the devs are
pretty much at his beck and call
he wants them to build a comment section
but he loses itunes
so he's not even on you open up gone
nothing exclusive
his audience size like potential has
literally been limited by like what one
tenth
of this size this is why people keep
saying like tim why aren't you on rumble
or whatever there's two reasons
two reasons the first is that someone
already got the username tim cast and
i'm not going to be bothered
maybe they'll give it to you i'm not
going to ask them well now i guess i
just said it on yeah
they'll email you
like every day we get like 10 people
being like you know 10 different
companies we started a new social media
company sign up we reserve your name i'm
like dude
yeah i keep telling everybody man
youtube is a money pit that loses money
like uber this is this is what silicon
valley does to destroy this country and
business in this country
uber loses money like crazy like dude
uber loses money
but here's the plan you subsidize the
cost through investors yep
until you strangle out all the
competition undercutting local cabs
cab drivers go nuts they were like cab
driver riots in france
i went to i was in i was in new york a
couple years ago and they were the cab
drivers protesting outside of city hall
saying that uber destroyed their
business and in order to drive a cabin
you need like a cab token and they cost
like a million bucks it's like you got
to pay off the loan
and so they were like we were told uber
would only be allowed to drive so many
cars
so we buy these things and then once
they brought in 30 000 uber cars
allowing them
then also these tokens are worthless and
no one drives in our cars anymore
so what happens is cabs cost more money
that's right you know why
because you got to pay for everything
the gas the the maintenance to repair
and the person's
the person's wage with uber same thing
applies
but it's cheaper because they eat the
cost take a huge loss
youtube does that youtube sinks is
money's on fire netflix does that too
they lose money like crazy
but they make money off of investing
they take money from investors or
through subsidies so youtube is
subsidized by the parent companies
the parent companies make sure youtube
functions and then
the the so the cost is ridiculous but
this makes it so that no one goes
anywhere else
and all they have to do now is wait
until everything withers and
is strangled i'll tell you it's simple
this it's it's simple as principle
really
you got a mom-and-pop cafe this was
happening in seattle at least this was a
story as i was told when i lived in
seattle a long time ago this was like 14
years ago
you'd have a mom and pop local family
small business cafe
one day a starbucks would open next door
and it would offer discounts super cheap
drinks
and then people would it would split
their business because there are some
people who are big fans of the local
cafe it's the best cafe you got to go
they make a great french roast
but then a lot of people are like i just
want a coffee starbucks they got
milkshakes or whatever you know
yeah and so they see the starbucks sign
and they know it's coffee and they see
the mom and pops you know
whiz-bang cafe and they're like i don't
know what that is you know what there's
a difference between
i would say there is it i agree with you
but i think there is a difference
between starbucks and uber
uber kind of innovated in industry
starbucks is just like a big corporation
that's right
i just mean the principal yeah yeah you
they they would people were telling me
that in seattle they were doing this i
just want to make sure that's clear it's
like what i was told
if it's true but they would say like
starbucks would open up right across the
street
then the small business would not be
able to compete with with starbucks
but you got bro in sierra uh in san
francisco
just off of market street remember
exactly where this what street this is
there's
there's like three starbucks three
starbucks locations
like in hollywood there's two or four of
them a mile away i went not even with
them
no in one point they're right across the
street from each other so i was walking
on the street looking for a starbucks i
pull up on my phone and it's like
two dots appear on my my google maps or
whatever and i'm like
which one what there's two of them and
so i walk and i look i'm like oh they're
starbucks
and then i walk inside i grab you know
like a water or whatever and i grab like
a thing of madeline's or some cookies
whatever they sell starbucks and when
i'm waiting in line i look across the
street and i see a starbucks logo on the
other side of the street
and i was like no you know what i use
it's true
i use that similar analogy when i'm
talking to people who like support
minimum wage increases
and i brought up to one guy i'm like hey
i'm like what do you think about um
restaurant owners paying
their employees 15 an hour he's like oh
you mean a livable wage
i'm like one a livable wage is different
depending on where you are and who you
are
right but i'm like i'm like you want to
increase minimum wage
i'm like do you not understand uh like
the overhead
that goes into running i just i use the
pizzerias analogy
you increase minimum wage now that
cashing is earned money the phone girl
needs to earn more money
now it costs more money for raw
materials now your pizza and price
go up and people get pissed off now
you're selling more expensive pizzas
because the minimum wage increase or
they start skimping on
materials they start skimping the
quality goes but then you have to see
them bro
but then a domino's opens up across it
this wouldn't fly
in new york or at least not in staten
island you know but anywhere else
uh a pizza hut or a dominoes opens up
across the street
and they can give you a pizza for one
tenth the price yeah and they can afford
to pay their employees
15 an hour because they have that
massive infrastructure to get you
cheap prices also if they subsidize it
with shareholders
so i'm like so you want 15 an hour
that's just going to destroy small
businesses
and then you're going to have to go work
for a corporation now you're stuck
making 15
an hour for the rest of your life
because you're working for pizza the
idea that you can artificially inflate
the wages for people
is just wrong man i talked to i i i told
her before i was talking to an
accountant
who was a he's a democrat guy he's like
you know urban democrat
not super political but you know he
votes down and i asked him about it
because new jersey was passing a
wage increase and he said oh i lost 30
of my clients already wow they just went
they shut their businesses down
overnight because what because what you
gotta do
is democrat he did does he still vote oh
no no no no dude
and that's why i'm like it's so it's so
crazy that i lived in a in a blue area
everybody was democrat and then within a
couple of years they were all trump
supporters
our whole lives we were riding the
bubble of the of the
the boomers is that what the boomers
they were just printing money and the
white picket fence
get a house the american dream was just
a big bubble they just kept printing
more and more and more money now there's
27 trillion that's
that's not the issue our whole lives we
arrived in that bubble we didn't realize
there's a lot of different issues as to
why
the boomers retain so much wealth and
young people not oil money
i think it has to do 45 boomers being
bad parents
i think that's to do with boomers being
some of the worst ignorant for sure they
didn't realize they were in that right
in that bubble too i don't think
there's it's not about writing the
american military bubble yeah so world
war ii we decimated the industries of
our
you know rival foreign countries and
then that's annoying
and then and then you have uh you know
american industry picks up the slack and
our factories were fine nobody came here
there's a lot of reasons why things were
doing well and there's a lot of
arguments about it but
there's a lot to be said everybody wants
to blame ronald reagan for trickle-down
economics as to why it happened
but they overlooked the fact that
republicans were and this is true back
the republicans want to start importing
a lot of cheap labor
and outsourcing to get cheap labor if
you were if you if you were in a factory
you know it's like the 70 like 70s and
80s
you're like man why do i got to pay you
know four bucks an hour five bucks an
hour to this employee
when i can have the stuff produced in in
mexico for dirt and then shipped up here
and so that that's where the train the
trend comes in the jobs get destroyed
and that's ultimately what leads us to
trump i think the reason i brought up
the bubble that we're in is because i
my whole life i thought if you need to
raise minimum wage raise the minimum
wage print make the short term value and
then later we can recoup the loss as a
short-term investment but
i didn't realize that it was like you
know what i i it's it's
it's so easy to explain my minimum wage
increases do not work what you need
is the the value of time to go up and
how you do that is
very complicated but here's it's really
easy to explain to somebody
if i'm growing apples and i gotta hire
someone at 10 bucks an hour to pick the
apples
and he can pick 10 apples per hour just
these are ridiculous numbers you can
have a pick more than that
then the cost of an apple has to be over
a dollar because then i got to pay for
overhead the machinery the planting
so apple costs two bucks well now you
double the guys wage right
let's say you you give 20 bucks an hour
now because because why not rashida
tulab was already saying you know 15 is
not enough 20 bucks
okay so now each apple has to cost at
least two dollars
now i all of a sudden apples go up in
price but guess what the people who pick
the apples
also need to eat so now i'm getting them
20 bucks an hour
and then they're going to the
supermarket and going i can't even buy
apples anymore because the price just
doubled
so you're not giving them buying power
increasing the minimum wage does not
give anyone buying it's like a
short-term buying point
no it's a it's a trick to make them
think it's a short term
as the inflation catches up it takes
like eight months it destroys the
savings
of retirees because now you still can't
buy the apple because you're the same
buying power
but now everybody who's saved can only
buy half the apples they originally
could have bought it
it does so much it one it helps out the
bigger business it hurts the little guy
it causes inflation it'll it allows the
government to tax you more as well
and also it spits in the face of the
people who maybe are trying to work
their way up at walmart you know maybe
hey
i put in 10 years at walmart i want to
work my way up you know i started at
five dollars an hour now you're making
20.
i got to tell you what i'm i got to tell
you what i'm really i'm sick of i am
sick of the fact
that you are left-wing or right-wing
based on whether you are
stupid and so when i go to a democrat
accountant
and he tells me look what happened on
paper to all of these businesses when
they raged
raise minimum wage the buying power did
not go up it stayed the same
and it destroyed these small businesses
that didn't have the savings
to maintain this one thing and then
everyone says because i'm not in favor
of minimum wage
it's a right-wing position so what the
left is stupid it's just an incomplete
uh concept to raise the wage you need to
raise like
in savings account interest as well i
think if you're gonna do something like
that so the banks
take a hit and the consumer can maintain
buying power interest that's not going
to do anything for somebody who makes 10
bucks an hour they don't have a savings
you don't see any increase in their
ideally it would help them grow savings
not only does it hurt business-wise
inflation-wise all that stuff
it also hurts the culture because if you
had a lower minimum wage
you know someone's first job at the age
of 13 14.
yeah his five dollars an hour worked the
cashier now the developer
425 i think i've been working i worked
my first job when i was like 13 14 years
old for like five dollars an hour and
you know
that's a growing experience everybody
shares that experience
now what kid is going to get a job when
the minimum wage is 15
an hour you're going to want to hire the
best of the best to make up for that
price
and the left always uses this argument
oh you go to in and out
they pay their employees above minimum
wage and look how good the service is
versus mcdonald's
it's like no they're not doing better
because they're getting a higher wage
they're doing better because they're
literally just picking the best of the
best fast food workers
and that's why they're getting paid more
because they're the best of the best and
because mcdonald's pays less
they're less concerned right because the
good the good
you know burger employees and cashiers
are going to be like i'm going to work
for in and out yeah i don't want to work
for
mcdonald's so the minimum wage really
pinned people like me when i worked in
the hospital because
i was a tech and i went to school for it
it didn't take very long but i was
making more than
the minimum wage because i had a little
bit of extra education
so one of the things i found was when my
state was raising the minimum wage was
that i
my wage would go up as well a little bit
at a time along kind of the same lines
and i wouldn't be able to buy or do
anything more it made
absolutely no difference everything the
price of everything stayed exactly the
same there's there's what are we doing
there's one benefit imports and so
that's why
you see people like joe biden tie
multiple multiple policies together with
the left free trade agreements
increase minimum wage higher corporate
taxes
drive the industry to foreign countries
give everybody in the u.s an increased
wage
but not the slave labor in china so the
people in china who are living
under a communist boot who live in
squalor to such a degree that they've
walked off of the foxconn buildings in
mass suicide incidents
and the foxconn lab had to put up nets
to catch people to stop from killing
themselves
they don't get a wage increase so what
happens with the minimum wage increase
that helps americans is that if you're
making 10 bucks an hour
and then they increase your wage to
congratulations
you can now buy it it's now easier for
you your buying power in terms of
import goods has gone up but you need to
maintain your slaves
that's the only one it's a slave economy
yeah
china abraham lincoln freed the slaves
but there's a lot more slaves that were
oh there's literal there's we're using
listen first of all slavery's never
there's more slaves alive today than
there's ever been
dude what the heck and it's it's you
know the the
obama's involvement in libya resulted in
the return of the north african slave
trade it's it's
it's it's insane i can imagine using
robots
as manufacturers because you know like a
computer slave but
you got for now you still need people to
do the finer uh manipulation
of you know like you know you can use
your hands to do better than yeah we
didn't even talk about the increase
in automation right yeah you know
mcdonald's
they have like one sometimes i'll go
into like a newer mcdonald's it'll be
like one person at the register and
five machines that you do well beyond
that
you go to the travel stops when you're
driving around the country and they have
a robot robot ice cream man you ever see
these things
yeah and it's like there's a little guy
it's like a creepy like cylinder
with little arms and its arm will spin
and then grab the cup and then go and
then it'll pull the lever down
fills the ice cream up and it's like
it's like staring at you with its like
creepy robotic gaze and then like the
sprinkles come down and it goes
i love it i think uh the automation
economy is inevitable and that the whole
job economy thing is probably going to
be a thing of the past
somebody's somebody's got to build the
robot somebody's got to design the
robots somebody got to maintain the
robots
electricity this has happened all
throughout history right you know one
yeah the fourth industrial revolution is
goes you know
in people i mean it's not like it used
to be where you can work a job for 20 30
years you need to constantly evolve
your brain and how you work and your
work ethic and your skills and your
knowledge
constantly you can't get comfortable
work or job for 30-40 years
obviously there's some jobs you can but
for the most part your job right now is
going to be obsolete
did i ever tell you the story about the
homeless guy i met in chicago
no so this is a story i tell a lot of
people and i probably told him on this
show but i i
there's a homeless guy i was skating in
downtown chicago when i was like 18 or
19.
and he looked like he he was like 60
years some old black dude
and i had some leftover pizza so i was
like i was like hey man i was like you
want some pizza i just
was leaving a restaurant and he was like
yeah for sure man i think he called me
youngblood or something
and i was like you got it bro and you
know fist bump and then i was like i ask
you a question a personal question
and i was like are you homeless and he
says yes sir i am and i was like how did
that happen
long story short he said listen man he's
like
you know i worked i think he worked for
the post office or something or he
worked he worked for some company
for years and then eventually when the
company started downsizing and they
didn't
they didn't need whatever the company
produced anymore you know one day
someone comes up to him and says
sorry man like company's going under
nobody buys this product for whatever
reason so
you know we're gonna have to let you go
you got about one more month so he loses
his job
and then he says the first thing he did
was he went to go find more jobs but
when you're an expert working at this
factory that produces a
specific product like what job are you
going to find to maintain yourself
he's like i got an apartment he's like i
got bills and i need a certain amount of
money
but because my skill is in this area
once i lose that job
i go to any other company i'll go to
he's like i go to mcdonald's i go to
wendy's
and they're like we'd love to hire you
seem great some places say you're over
quality qualified you were a manager oh
sorry we can't hire you
but even if they do you're making you go
from making 20 bucks a 10 bucks
he's like i got a job but i still
couldn't afford my bills
eventually i start you know my car gets
taken my i can't afford my rent anymore
then eventually the the you know the
landlord comes and he says if you don't
pay your rent by this time i'm kicking
you out and he's like listen man he's
like i'm old man
he's like my friends and my family they
they're gone many people have passed
and then one day they come to me and say
you can't pay your rent you're gone he's
like i
exhausted unemployment benefits i had
nothing left and now here i am
yeah we're going to see a lot of that
happen now because of the lockdowns
we're going to see
ex-business-owned restaurant owners
being managers at mcdonald's
if they're lucky oh get under the boot
of the corporate machine
man that's what you know what you don't
really bothers me i want to go back to
this
the minimum wage is stupid and i
will assert myself as left on economic
policy
everything i just explained about this
guy losing his job and becoming homeless
is a problem brought up by economic
leftists
but i'm not stupid enough to think the
minimum wage solves that problem and you
know who's
for the lockdowns right now bill gates
it's the left yeah
the leftists you know who are destroying
like listen
there are there are republicans who are
ignoring it like i said you know the
democrats
in these in these in these uh cities and
states have destroyed the economy
and they've turned people from small
business owners with their own little
you know private space and fiefdom and
ownership that made them happy
and they've pushed them down into the
poverty class and they want them to live
under the boot of corporations
and it is the left in this country that
is doing it the left is supposed to be
saying
that government is good government is
good we all work together
we do socialism and the people are are
in this together the democrats
they're using the power of government to
force people to work for mcdonald's
that's the left the democrats future
they want it to be just you know
10 20 30 big trillion dollar
corporations
and the rest of the rest of the country
just works for them that's the democrats
socialist future
and it's so crazy because they have the
voters
fooled they have the voters fool that
that's fighting for the people
they hate these big corporations they
hate the billionaires but
everything that they're supporting is
funded and supported by the same people
they say they hate they're being
so duped i was making the most
in any like medial job the most money
ever made i wasn't making minimum wage i
was making two dollars and 13 cents an
hour as a waiter
and i was getting tips based on
percentages of sales
so i was making percentages of what the
company was making and that was the best
living i could make
so maybe we don't need minimum wage
maybe we need like a guaranteed percent
of the doctors
at the very left the democrats in some
areas i know they were doing this with
uber they were they were fighting
for waiters and waitresses to make
minimum wage yes no more tip economy
if you're a waiter and a waitress you
don't want to make minimum wage no
you're
taxed if you work at a good yeah you get
taxed too if you work at a good bar you
can come home with a couple thousand in
it and if it's cash it's not i mean they
say to declare all your tips but
every waiter i know unless it's under
the time if that's why that's why you
always make sure you
yeah all your credit cards leave it
there tip with cash so that
it's on the waiter no no no no pay your
taxes yeah and pay your taxes
i know people who do waitering and the
people who do it full time as a
full-time job they'll claim like half
of their ticket but also how is it that
if you help me move some boxes and i
give you 50 bucks the
no you need to go tell the government
yeah that's crazy i mean
get off my back you know that's probably
another reason why the democrats want
corporate america because
everything goes through the tax that's
why they want digital currencies too yes
they want everything to be
tracked and and everything you know so
look i've i'll try and keep this vegas
as possible because i don't want to you
know reveal people's private information
but i have
friends when i was growing up where one
dude goes to college gets a degree
and then he gets out and the job he gets
with that degree pays him like 15 bucks
an hour and he's happy he's like yeah i
got a degree it's an entry level
position you know i'm 22.
and then i have friends who go and serve
you know
uh like at a restaurant you know like a
steakhouse
and they make 50 bucks an hour yeah they
don't want minimum wage
i opened up my own small business a few
years ago i opened up a grilled cheese
so you're a fascist
i opened up a grilled cheese joint
called get grilled nice really
yeah and does it still exist no no no we
wanted to turn it into a brand it was
like a subway for grilled cheeses
amazing it was awesome but subway can do
grilled cheese
i mean you don't go there for daily use
right right good bread good cheese
yeah and it was a really good idea it
was awesome everybody that visit was
like wow this is going to be big this is
awesome they're so good the grilled
cheeses we had
we made the process like as similar to
to like that streamlined process to make
things like
yeah and uh the thing is after doing
that realizing all the regulations of
coming in
how expensive it was because of the
taxes my employees made way more money
than me
yep and i had to end up paying them out
of the pocket because it wasn't
profitable
and um one of the reasons was when the
mall that we were in was really bad and
then two
just like the regulations of them coming
in all this useless stuff that we don't
need
and then some like idiot who's coming
there and like you know making sure
everything's up to code made us put like
this six
foot like what we what you see now when
you go into a store and there's like
that glass shield
they made us put that over the food yeah
and like
when we're talking to the customers we
gotta like lean over because they can't
hear us because the wall is like curved
there's
they're like that's just like
unnecessary like what like
there's a there's a metric where they
they there's a question
there's a correlation between the
strength of a country's economy
and the ease at which an individual uh
has to start a business
the harder it is to start a business the
worse economies do
and i'll tell you we talked about this
you know last week in indonesia i'm
sorry
real quick and also in that same mall
all the similar businesses
were all owned and ran by the business
owner exactly they would work 12-hour
shifts now the only way they can be
profitable sorry
i'll cut you off in tunisia the arab
spring started because a guy was trying
to sell fruit from a cart and the
government kept blocking him and
wouldn't let him so eventually he just
went in front of a building and set
himself on fire
but i'll tell you this you think grilled
cheese is a good idea you want to know
the best idea ever for
for a fast casual restaurant what you go
in
all right and there's three key food
items
three food items that's what we saw and
then sides and unit is
it's chicken tikka masala it's pod thai
and it's orange chicken
yeah so those are actually like the top
uh that's kind of like went into the top
fries and burgers and that's why they're
able to i'm half kidding though
but like i had this idea because i was
reading about the top things ordered
from
you know whatever i love it it's like
pod thai chicken tikka masala and orange
chicken and i was like put them all in
one fast casual place
you know call it super you know what you
could do i'm going to reveal this idea
online maybe someone will build it you
make combinations where
they can go in and they can decide what
oil they want they want coconut
olive you know sesame oil
and then what vinegar they want do they
want rice wine what you just depict the
oil in the vinegar that goes in there
changes the flavor completely there's a
place in uh there's a chain in new york
that does that and you'll be like i'd
like a white wine vinegar
and then coconut oil and they have a
fridge for a lot of different kinds of
lettuce they have like spinach spring
greens romaine iceberg
and then they have the different meats
and then they have different fish yeah
yeah different fish when you walk in
you'll say i'll do spring greens
with grilled chicken and i'll do you
know the white wine vinegar with
crispy onions and mushrooms and then
they take it all and then they cook it
in front of you as you walk down the
line it's really
all about that oil and that vinegar man
for now it's called is that the one
where they cook it on like
a thing with like sticks that's hibachi
no no no no
it's kind of like chipotle you walk and
you get in line and then you walk up and
say what do you want and you're like
spring greens you know steak the more
and they cut they cook the steak and
they cut in front of you it's amazing so
the thing is like
with the restaurant industry the more
you add to the menu the more
options you give it just adds more
to the start to the cost of running
things because then you know if you have
more items you need
more space because at first obviously at
first too just keep your base
ingredients like
yeah you want a salmon you want like a
steak and like
that's why also chipotle chicken that's
why yeah like chipotle is so streamlined
it's like you know four different types
of meats
three different two different types of
rice two different types of beans and
you can make all these different types
of combinations
same thing with in and out it's just
burgers and fries
so it's like they can handle 100
customers every 10 minutes
because it's only burgers and fries
they're just mess cooking it and getting
it out the door
yeah well if they had the make to order
at in and out you'll be online for six
hours and then you have in seattle you
have dicks
do you know dicks in seattle last resort
no it's just called this oh
it's a hamburger joint called dicks and
so the reason it's tasty
the reason why they do really well
though is not because they they just
sell burgers and fries and milkshakes i
think
but you want to know why that that
business does really well
because when i'm in seattle my friends
go you want to eat a bag of dicks
i'm not always saying yes no i'm not
kidding i'm not kidding
and so and then and then the first time
i heard that i was like haha very funny
like no no dicks
burger joint and i'm like wait what no
yeah it's a burger joint like hell yeah
oh burgers
but think about it think about it all of
a sudden you're like
someone right like what do you want to
do tonight let's go out
let you know let's go eat a bag of dicks
and you're like like banging
and then everyone's laughing so somebody
gets the joke and then you actually go
and buy the burgers right so it's like
it's clever marketing yeah clever
marketing
but you know anyway we were talking
about dick's a funny word
it's a guy's name that's right you know
you don't really creeped me out i saw a
billboard once in seattle
and it was a pig grilling bacon or
something what
yeah it was like a billboard for like a
smoke house or like like barbecue
and it was like a smiling pig with a
chef's hat and he was like frying bacon
and i was like jeez
yeah pigs will eat each other i believe
yeah they will yeah luke was telling us
about that
luke uh uh was saying that you know that
he was on a farm with a bunch of pigs
and the pigs will like bite you because
they're trying to eat you and you gotta
like kick them back and stop them
they're hungry and then he was saying
that
what they do when that when you're on a
farm and there's no food and you're like
struggling or starving
they'll [ __ ] one of the pigs and the
other pigs will just eat it
oh wow crazy dude pigs are nuts i'm
gonna go to the bathroom i'll be back
anyway regulation joey regulation
destroys small businesses
oh yeah i mean i've seen it first hand
and it's you know
i was at this one place yesterday tim
what was the name of it it was in staten
island and the guy got arrested
oh yeah yeah you went to that bar max uh
pub house republican yeah yeah yeah
you went there yeah i went there we were
just all hanging out oh that's right
because you're a former congressional
candidate from staten island that's
right yeah
no former loser so uh a former loser you
did lose i did lose yeah
ongoing loser ongoing loser so
um what they did was they did all the
legal loopholes
to get it past lockdowns they're um you
know an autonomous zone
they're uh chapel now i told them i'm
like
just put a black lives matter sign on
the front because de blasio says that's
okay
yeah but even though they're doing all
the legal loopholes
it does not matter because the democrats
agenda like their their law is a sliding
scale even though you're following it
i don't like it we're going to shut you
down in particular it's they're
broke bro yeah
there'd be there'd be no [ __ ] this guy
would not be shut down if the cops
weren't enforced exactly
i heard that my people were telling me
that it's
not so much to nypd but the sheriff and
the state troopers nypd
they came to my family's restaurant
multiple times they don't give a damn
they come
whatever oh i never told you this story
so my family's restaurant opened up in
the summer when they allowed some of the
outdoor dining and then the um uh health
official came
and analyzed the place or whatever
everybody was wearing a mess they were
all up to code
some people were wearing masks that
weren't like mask masks but they were
like a face
visor like a see-through like plastic
visor i guess that wasn't okay yeah it's
got to be cloth
yeah and the guy comes in he looks
around
and he takes the liquor license away
just what and right like right like that
right then and there
wow and then it goes to i guess
uh the can you give the booze away if
you have no liquor license
that's another loophole that i think max
was doing yeah
giving the food away and then just had a
donation yeah yeah yeah
um but yeah the loopholes don't matter
right right um
then i went online and i found the
liquor authority
their live stream of them all talking
and
declaring for every business okay we're
gonna find them
fifty thousand dollars okay we're gonna
find them thirty thousand dollars but
uh they have to shut the music off at 10
o'clock like all these rules
trying to punish businesses and these
are unelected people
sitting in a position of power and trust
me they're the stupidest looking people
you look at them you're like
these people should be bums on the
street and
they're the ones like dictators deciding
what businesses are allowed to do
and the fines that they have you gotta
get out of new york city yeah
and i saw them they did the whole thing
on my family's restaurant it was
completely wrong
they were looking at photos they had
drone footage and they said yeah we see
people not wearing masks by the pool
um they they listed off a bunch of other
things i forgot what it was but
everything they listen
there's no pool yeah that's what i'm
trying to say there's no pool i was like
that's kind of weird everything they
were listing off
was not even true and was not even like
they must have
had the information from them well they
don't care
and there's no appeal process you can't
state your case
it's just whatever they say you're
you're actually wrong
on all counts just because some random
person says it doesn't make it true
like if a random person is like we're
we're you know we're shutting you down
but who are you yeah exactly i'm the
health inspector says who yeah that's my
badge what badge was that from
all right then they send the students
over and then come back with the police
arrest you come back with a warrant
i told myself and then get arrested i
told my mom next time they come
next time they come you tell you take
your phone out you start recording you
tell them they have
no legal constitutional rights to come
here and do what they're doing and you
kick them out and you tell them to come
back
never like you kick them out you say
you're banned from the premises do not
come back here
you know what man i guess this isn't
true for a staten island stan you guys
you guys elected max rose all right he's
out now yeah he's out now but
look am i supposed to have sympathy for
new yorkers who
keep voting for these people see staten
island does not vote for any of those
we want to succeed from the city from
the city
the city won't let us because the city
knows okay if we look
at that what's the city going to do to
stop you that's what i'm saying like why
aren't we just doing it will the city
file us
file a claim with the state or the
supreme court new york city
taxes and then there's state taxes
that's crazy
and the city will not let us leave
because everybody in manhattan would
immediately move to staten island yeah
all the big businesses will move over
there to avoid the taxes no they'd move
to jersey city man if they do that too
but i'm saying
staten island still got to pay taxes
will live in jersey city yeah staten
island will
like there'll be a mass exodus from
manhattan over this and it'll make the
democrats look bad because everyone's
fleeing just like they're fleeing now
everyone from staten island
kind of abandoned ship in the most part
they're just going to florida ulysses
s grant says anybody who feels like
they're oppressed by their government
has a right to revolution yeah
that was that's ulysses man yes that's
the north you know what's um i love stat
i've been there a couple times i was
there for hurricane sandy i did with
occupy
sandy i did clean up in staten island
yeah where they
boats would be washed up onto people's
lawns sounds crazy dude
what's um the middle of the island like
i've only ever been to the you know how
like
roads will go around and then the middle
it looks like just like wilderness and
mountains
there's a lot of wooded areas but
everything's you know being starting to
be torn down for more houses
the property value i heard from a
realtor was actually going up
because it's one of the places people
are leaving manhattan for even though
you're still part of new york city it's
just less crime
but this is the thing you you know that
people in new york city
don't consider staten island new york
city that's the thing every every
liberal leftist democrat in new york
city is like f staten island
it's not new york city yeah they tell me
that brooklyn was in new york city
be a part of you just let us leave now
they want your money dude we just want
our money like you hate us
the leaders hate us the voters hate us
we don't want to be a part of this
fun though yeah that would be
interesting to break up the boroughs it
is man going from from
you know was like battery park or
whatever finance then you take the boat
staten island yeah
brooklyn and queens are kind of
connected like they're so interwoven
it'd be tough to break those into two
cities
man queen's is massive yeah they don't
realize it is very big
yeah it's the biggest borough isn't it
right yeah yeah it's ridiculously big
yeah but staten island i think i've been
there three times and i lived in new
york for five years
three times i've been to staten island
but i would go to the bronx harlem
queens brooklyn manhattan all the time
like couple times a day you're bouncing
around
you've got a friend on the upper west
side that come over across the bridge
come to the bronx or whatever
yeah like sure and all the democrats
they like to say uh staten island's a
big pile of
big dump hey it's the only like borough
you can have a clean nice backyard not
triple serious people in the streets i'm
like you hate on it because you ain't it
is the city of new york extracting the
wealth from the boroughs and then
centralizing it in manhattan i don't
really know
well well yes but if we replace the word
manhattan with
like de blasio's pockets mansion
yeah like his wife getting two million
dollars for her staff for whatever
million dollars went missing or
something yeah yeah
new york you gotta love it you know uh
uh i think new york
if you live in new york city you have
the second highest taxes in the country
yeah because of the city tax yeah that's
good city
income tax city city state and federal
california is the highest income tax
people are flying here california wants
to do
if you spend at least 60 days in
california
non-consecutive they'll tax you for 10
years
wow good luck that's why i'm moving to
vegas zero state taxes oh but they got
you all right
they got you right they got you you're
moving at the beginning of the year
don't matter
if they pass this bill they pass this
law or whatever they're going to come
after you
now let's be let's be real what are they
going to do california state trooper
going to show up in vegas
right no they'll just shut my bank
accounts down if they're counting
they're based
yeah oh no i'm doing everything all my
documents california california
has uh this year i think they lost 140
000 people
net negative migration over the past
several years yeah
california is collapsing i want to give
a shout out to vegas i love that city if
you
go to the outskirts where it's like it's
there'll be houses
and then there's desert like your front
yard is desert and you can see
mountains and then behind you is the
city lights of vegas
yeah but you know that vegas is being uh
uh
they're reversing what's it called
reverse desertification or whatever
a desert reclamation so because people
who move to vegas want lawns
they import water where from like people
move to vegas
and then they want lawns because they
don't want desert what if they'll start
seeding you know how they're in abu
dhabi they're rain seeding they don't
need to do
that there's already clouds popping up
all over vegas
to the desert because of the lawns
because people because the lawns
are holding moisture and people are
watering them and the water is cycling
back
and so the more people move in also
pools and the more pools and the more
grass
dude well i've noticed all the houses
that i looked at when i went on my
search
i don't think i saw maybe one house with
a lawn good but a lot of the houses had
fake grass and then obviously desert
shrubbery that's what i've noticed
check this out people maybe in the
summerlin i could see this i'll tell you
something really crazy
people go to vegas to vacation right so
you get on a plane and while you're on
the plane
you use a bathroom there's a lot of
water in your in your poop and you're in
your urine right
the plane dumps all that off in vegas
when they clean out the system
we are importing fluids from human
beings
not only that they got to import soda
and water and drinks
for all of the tourists who keep coming
in exhale water yes exactly when you
exhale water so people
every time people come to vegas it's
getting like i remember i was there
and it was partly cloudy and i'd been to
vegas like a decade ago and it was
like some man-made lakes there too yeah
yeah yeah we're importing water like
crazy
and then the grass is really what's
retaining it so we're turning the vegas
into you know green like we're terrible
terraforming yeah it's crazy i wonder if
that mojave that's the mojave desert
is that that desert i think it's mojave
um if that's a left
if that's sediment deposit left over
from the flood twelve thousand eight
hundred years ago that north american
glacial flood that just dumped
it's gaze this is the landscape and then
dropped
it's all sand like i know the sahara is
ocean sand if you look at it just got
pushed up
onto the continent and i wonder if this
is also like if we could remove that
sand if there would be
fresh dirt underneath that's interesting
i don't think it matters i think humans
are inadvertently terraforming just
raining on top of it because
that that the grass is going to turn
into dirt eventually that's awesome and
then we're going to grow more grass and
we just keep bringing it import dirt
no for real people are so we are like
that's crazy we could i wonder what we
could do to the sahara too
because that what they've been doing
with the sahara is they've been planting
trees along the desert line
to stop the desert from growing because
it's killing and you know
it expands so they keep planting trees
and trying to you know big ones and so
it blocks the
the spread of the desert we could we
could you know turn more
places green man yeah i'd like to put
all that ocean sand back into the ocean
at some point it's like it's going to
shovel one at a time yeah
or we could maybe use drones to start
carting it now and get it done
drones can't carry that much weight one
by one if you have a hundred million
drones and they're
carrying 20 minutes that's all you need
one cup at a time
let's do this let's let's let's let's
talk about this uh uh let's talk about
aliens
yes that's what will be the last we
talked about super chats afterwards but
check this out
huge ball of fire falls from the sky and
crashes into a chinese county
leaving locals stunned giant fireball
was spotted flashing across the sky
over nankyon china footage shows the
burning sphere exploding and plumbing
into the country
let me play this video for you guys all
right and play this video
wait what what is this what okay no
that's a video of a mob attack for some
reason what is this
yeah that plays that's so dumb all right
let's refresh daily mail
and let's play the the look at this this
is crazy wow
it's like the sun
you can hear people yelling in chinese
and it crashed into the ground
apparently
what was that was that at night that was
at night oh it looks like day time
look at watch once it goes over the
ridge you see it get dark holy [ __ ]
object exploding into a blazing sphere
plunging you know i feel bad for the
aliens
they're probably doing routine
surveillance and then they malfunction
burst into flames and now we're sitting
here watching and of all the places
china i want it was probably i mean now
20 new religions
satellite probably to 28 right satellite
does make the most sense
but uh let's entertain the idea because
we were supposed to get aliens this year
right remember that dude from israel
said aliens are real yes did you see
that joke
in canada yeah a guy we had a guy in
canada like 10 years ago
former like defense minister or whatever
said yep aliens are real
and he basically said we need a one
world government or something like that
you know hey it could be a false flag
for globalism
i need aliens you need i'm desensitized
by twitter and now i need
i have aliens yeah i'm you know what man
yes
we need aliens i'm bored i'm so ready so
dude listen listen listen donald trump
filed some like lawsuit or whatever in
pennsylvania to like overturn the
results
and i was like i don't want to do
another segment talking about because he
just did it again like a couple days ago
and it's like here we go another claim
challenging it for many of the same
reasons and i'm like really man
can an alien just like come with a jet
pack and land so we can change the
subject that'd be cool
i mean talk about something else we'll
throw them in cages yeah yeah probably
the
illegal illegal aliens illegal aliens
yeah maybe meditation but aliens
i prefer it aliens would be fun so i'm
gonna ask i may be playing too many
ian let me ask you the obvious question
why didn't they go and scoop up this
this thing that crashed okay it landed
across it's definitely a satellite
there's multiple videos like government
crazy it's like this is in china look at
this look at this video
it was it's like it's night out and it
looks like daylight whatever this is
that's big yeah dude
it's a bunch of illegal aliens it looked
it looked like a bolide a very bright
meteor
very convenient or it was aliens firing
off there
if that was a meteor wouldn't there be a
little bit more of an explosion on the
ground when it hit the ground
yeah like i don't know hit the ground
yeah wouldn't something happen i don't
know if it would explode
let's see the the non xiang county
government told red star news that it
had heard the matter but was unclear of
the details
that must be scary and then daily mail
gives us this really great breakdown of
what an asteroid comet meteor meteoroid
meteorite is thank you what's the
difference
an asteroid is a chunk of rock left over
from collisions of the early solar
system mostly located between mars and
jupiter
a comet is a rock covered in ice methane
and other compounds it orbits take them
further and solar system and meteor
is what astronomers call a flash of
light in the atmosphere when debris
burns up
a meteoroid is the debris itself but
most are so small they vaporize the
atmosphere
and if any of this meteoroid makes it to
earth it's called meteorite
that's so dumb that's why you see
comments like there's a comment that
like comes back because it's like stuck
in the end it keeps returning
and it's ice so an asteroid's rock
second comet is eyes
and a meteor is when it enters the
earth's atmosphere dude when i saw this
i thought it was day out
and then i just watched the video and i
realized it was actually night time what
if it was uh
the exposure of the camera got messed up
and that's all it is not because there's
multiple videos of it no no
oh i mean uh
uh the other video where it shows it's
really dark out
yeah and then you see it light up yeah
like in this video it's like really dark
out there's no sun
it could be some new military equipment
that went wrong
yeah baby yeah yeah china could be
testing some kind of crazy weapons
and that's it do you think aliens are
real joe
of course do you think they're here i
mean if they're real they would be here
why why would they be here i don't know
because they're probably you're going to
go and hang out like watch ant hills
i guess some i guess some people do you
know what i mean what if what if like
aliens are just like little kids
watching stupid humans who dumb human
stuff and we think they're like this
like intelligent races can't come here
like think about you
staring at an ant hill just watching
them do their thing and being like it's
crazy it's like
yeah so just like looking at it because
you're like or like imagine watching
pigeons
and you're like wondering where the baby
baby pigeons are because you never see
them you'll never see full grown pigeons
what if that's what it is it's like the
aliens who come here are just driving by
and it's like it's like rubber necking
they're like driving by earth and
they're like oh look at all these people
down there what are they doing
and then people are like the aliens are
here they're gonna kill us all and the
aliens are like i gotta go to jim's
house wherever yeah we're like huh
people we're definitely
in a relevant spec to them maybe yeah
we got nuclear weapons i guess that's
concerning it just depends on where the
aliens are in terms of
uh ability and technology you gotta
think all of existence what billions or
trillions of years i don't know how
long of existence and how long have we
existed and then there's all that time
before so who knows they can be 100
million year civilization which could be
infinite amounts of time yeah the big
bang is just one of many
rubber banding explosions of coalescence
of
matter and then propulsion what if we're
the first
that's statistically impossible no it's
not i mean it is possible statistically
but i mean it's actually one of the
answers to fermi's paradox
yeah are you familiar with fermi's
paradox or no no it's just it's this
idea like if
if the universe is this big and it's
existed for this long
and life is produced at this rate
shouldn't we have seen
aliens at some point or some evidence of
them and there's a bunch of different
it's a question basically and there's a
bunch of different answers as to why we
haven't one of the scariest ones is
called the great filter
the great filter is this idea that all
civilizations intelligent civilizations
come to a point where they destroy
themselves
yeah that's the idea that the globalists
have the climate change people that's
why they want the authoritarian lockdown
because they feel like humanity will
wipe itself out with war
with famine with death with with
pollution and destruction
unless we control every aspect of their
lives that's not
that i don't believe that's true but if
they destroyed themselves and then
rebuilt
and then that's you know well they kept
destroying themselves well the idea is
like if we if if we fired off every nuke
and every arsenal and in a mutually
short destruction this planet would be a
smoldering rock
i think these other we're humans they
could have evolved
differently right they could be giant
floating sacks of gas or wolf
people yeah or like what if what if
they're giant ants that just work
together like a hive mind you have sex
with with tentacles for arms and they
don't care about like our idea of
emotions and everything might not exist
and whatever these aliens are you could
breathe methane
there's so many champions okay so our
universe was formed it looks like it was
mitosis
that formed our moon um planet thea
after the
cataclysm of the unit of the solar
system's creation 3.6 billion years ago
24 planetoid bodies all colliding one of
them smashed into earth they call it
thea and then it came out the other side
like this form of
wall and that mitosis slowly cooled into
the moon this perfect magnetic
shape that blocks out the sun exactly
between the earth and the sun not at the
time yeah the moon is
really close and yeah yeah and it looks
like it's magnetically all kind of held
in place
but gravity that's the reason why we
grew up on this planet is because we had
that moon
pulling the tides and like evolving our
bodies it's possible that that is a
chemical reaction that's common
throughout the universe that
that planetoid mitosis so maybe but i
haven't i don't think we've ever located
another solar system where we can
condemn that that is did they find water
on mars water particles i think
so who knows well they're not sure i
think they recanted that or whatever but
there's a ton of earth-like planets
yeah you know i guess the the the issue
though is you know going back to fermi's
paradox
the great filter is one of the problems
the other is we might be the first
we might be the first intelligent
species it's possible
i think it's unlikely but defy
intelligent
capable of manipulating their
environment and you know i think that
there's like
a planet of little dinosaurs running
around probably
yeah yeah little dinosaurs they were
here somewhere if that's there
eventually they would evolve
something like us not necessarily
evolution isn't linear yeah like
intelligence isn't necessarily going to
get necessarily going to guarantee your
survival
so we we eventually i think it's like 40
000 years ago humans got to the point
where they were like
hey i realized something i can like use
this rock to do a thing yeah
you ever see that video of the of the
orangutan spear fishing
oh yeah i saw that they're saying like
orangutans are reaching like some kind
of like caveman state where they're like
using tools
that's why i think the aliens spliced
our dna
[Laughter]
wow well that's like one of the famous
conspiracy theories that aliens took
primates and spliced their dna we don't
have to miss them
we do have the missing link though i i i
heard that there's like
millions of years ago we murdered
like 20 years ago there was the missing
link that people would cite for
evolution that's why they didn't believe
it and then we found the missing link
and they said well what about the
missing link between this and the next
one
yeah there's always a missing link then
we found it then we found it and we've
actually gone way back
and then we found i think it's called
lucy yeah the oldest human ancestor like
a circle
yeah yeah so you found evidence of this
stuff there's like people back then
we're
smaller too yeah well yeah i don't know
if that went bigger than that
in like 1900 people were like five foot
six yeah now they got tall and now
i heard that the napoleon complex like
of him being short and
whatever he was just normal right
exactly
and the reason people think he was short
is because his guards were big
because he would clearly pick the big
strong dudes together and the british
intentionally ran with it to make fun of
them
spread that rumor that makes sense you
ever hear of the stoned ape theory
what's that the um apes that we evolved
from apes but it was because they
started eating marijuana
and mushrooms psilocybin and started to
the brains
chemistry charts changing intelligence
yeah i think joe's talked about a lot
and i'm all about like animal not i'm
not into animal cruelty but i would love
to corral a bunch of apes and feed them
mushrooms
and just watch them see if they want to
eat it yeah and just let them get
optional
so maybe that's what we are for another
species here's here's a a
a thought experiment thing so i guess
you know a lot of religious people
believe that you know us humans we're
the only ones with the soul
and then like i guess animals have life
forces but then obviously we know
evolution is a real thing we know we
evolved from something
and let's just say we evolved from apes
at what point in that
common ancestor yeah and like at what
point in that evolutionary process does
one have a soul and one dozen if you do
believe in all that
you know is there like the mom like
where is that one point well
there are there are interesting things
we talked about this on the on the show
with michael and alex
uh alex jones the pre-cambrian explosion
there's a period in the fossil record
where all of a sudden there's just a ton
of different species
and there's a bunch of different
explanations for why it is but people
often look at that and say like you had
very limited life then you had a bunch
of different species all around the same
time something happened
and uh you know there's weird weird
stuff we can't answer you know what i
think
people need to realize too if we look
back
scientifically with carbon dating with
fossil records with you know looking at
the sedimentary
layers of like you know when things
happen you can see like volcanic ash you
can see like radiation
it's all really well and good because
the logic is there
but you wouldn't be able to look back
and find a spaceship
so like the point i'm making is while i
don't know a lot of weird stuff in the
egyptian stuff
like the helicopters and spotlights but
here's the point in the bible
i mean yeah spaceships moses followed a
beaming light in the sky
was it was it he went behind a rock and
god gave him a tablet
yeah electricity is not that hard to
make with vinegar and iron
there's some there's some like there's
like some book where a dude goes up to
heaven and meets god
or something like that well oh uh mary
was thrown up there's a heaven body and
soul there's
moses moses went up a mountain and spoke
no there's a guy who got beamed up
yeah but hot air balloons are super
simple contraptions
you might be thinking of john with a
little bit of propulsion like
electromagnetic heat
on a hot air balloon um hang gliders
super easy to make i wonder if they got
into the orbit though because then you
need no i'm talking about the book of
enoch yeah okay so that's not in the
bible
just so you know right right right right
it's it's the hebrew thing it's
apocalyptic religious text it was
removed from the bible
yes and uh i was removed from the bible
by who yeah who has the authority to do
this yeah they had councils about this
yeah this is the council of nicaea yeah
the first one
i don't think it was the first one that
was i'm pretty sure this is a story of
the guy who like
was brought to heaven um yeah dude i
want a copy of the og bible before nicea
got their hands on it
i'm sure it'd be interesting talking
about drugs talking about how much acid
they all dropped
or ergot at the time i don't think
there's so many like
theories of what the bible could be
about it could be drugs could it be
aliens
could it be really you know god could
just be like all of the above
it could be a collection of stories to
help guide people and that's and
that's what i tell people all the time
like whether you believe in you know god
or not or jesus or not i'm like the
bible is is
a book of how to live your life like
like listen listen a good person yeah
with the don't eat shellfish and don't
eat pork thing like i mean
yeah it's a safety thing yeah it's like
telling people like here's the things
that are gonna you should live by and it
was you know
uh bronze age individuals doing the best
of their abilities and it was an attempt
at explaining a lot of things
and with limited knowledge they created
the book man it's called the books that
bible means
oh interesting what language is that i
don't know what he means
dude i'm into the miracles the dudes
biblioteca like if you've ever done
reiki have you ever practiced reiki
where you use like your magnetic field
to put energy
into other people or withdraw so did
jesus trust me
and uh he was apparently a healer like
an energy healer so i think he went and
learned reiki in like india
and then came back and had all this like
us right he was only 33 and that's not
recording
he disappeared in his 20s and no one
knows where he went you know it wasn't
like 13 to 30 he was
he was like in the east practicing or
meditating with like yogi's and stuff
don't know kung fu and stuff
yeah not kung fu like martial arts no
i'm free like i think that he went and
trained
you know and i don't know if that's true
because not in the bible but there's a
lot of people
there's like different cultures have
depictions of jesus and
all of these depictions are of their
particular ethnicity it's interesting
there's like a drawing of jesus in like
east asia and he's like asian it's
definitely an idea of
21 jump street and apparently that's all
related to aliens and other weird
yeah drugs or whatever let's read super
chats yes
if you have not already smash that like
button throw on your super chats we're
going to read your comments now
everybody
merry christmas again benjamin says who
is john galt
i don't know who is that he's a guy who
is john galt
i'm i'm just going to shrug that one off
yeah right well that's a good question
to ask when we have joey
saying that he's leaving california and
we're talking about who is john galt as
a reference to
atlas shrugged i believe an iran novel
and a group of capitalists that
has decided they've had it with
societies overbearing arches and want to
go create their own magical
community on staten island yeah just
kidding about the staten island
that's where it'll be let's see where do
they make it in the book is it like a
fictitious
yeah it's in like west virginia i think
or something that's where we're going
gemcast says hey what do you think about
a new executive power so the president
can do a super veto where congress can't
overrule
of course he would get a set amount of
these but this would stop the omnibus
packages
i don't know about that i think the
founding fathers were pretty clever with
how they set everything up
and the fact they're trying to curtail
the president's power to invoke the
insurrection act
like negates the point of the executive
branch the executive is supposed to be
able to act quickly and decisively in
the face of a threat
congress being like well you gotta get
our approval kind of just takes that
power away
which is kind of ridiculous so that's a
bad thing in my opinion
doctor certifiable says if biden is
compromised can't the u.s just out bribe
china so he works for us that's
it yes oh yeah gtr35 says ethereum is
down
time to buy i just bought some bitcoin
aery holbrun says merry christmas tim
and crew thank you for all you do
keeping me informed and entertained at
work both
appreciate christmas all right let's see
max lenk says tim you are dead wrong
about what would happen
as fallout of repealing section 230 it
would not be a mass exodus the way you
make it out to be
it would be an instant barrage of
lawsuits against twitter facebook and
youtube
and then they would have to shut down
the services to stop this from happening
and they'd probably do it before section
the repeal went into effect
there's just i just don't see a way
around that they have no liability
liability protection and they have
hundreds of millions of users
and you know trump will immediately sue
ev like to twitter for every fake news
story
and there would be no protection now
theoretically twitter could try and
claim
anti-slap defense but then twitter has
to pay for all of this
for the defense for these filings for
each user that's crazy no for each suit
for each lawsuit so if trump said i'm
suing twitter
3578 times for all of the fake news put
out by these lists of journalists
all these individual defamation suits
targeting twitter now i'm not saying
you'd actually do that that's obscene
but it would probably be rolled up into
one suit listing all of these as
infractions
everyone would start doing it maybe not
everybody but it would be enough for
these big companies to be like we cannot
assume that liability
so we are going to put a pause on
everything and then only verified people
i don't know
twitter would function twitter twitter
twitter literally is a machine that
generates
fake news and defamation that's all it
does twitter is not telling you any any
secrets
twitter's not informing you as to the
true realities and nature of this world
twitter is a place where political
activists go and talk crap about each
other it's the source of cancer culture
yes yes that's the direct source twitter
is terrible ban twitter and all you need
is a thousand so maybe
maybe section 230 should be gone no
because you need internet video is good
internet no but you'll have your own
website you make your own websites
that's what we need
yeah make your own website do it anyway
yep
and then there could theoretically be a
workaround for new platforms that could
arise without 230
that would bypass this by not
restricting in any capacity any
publishing capabilities
there's probably interesting workarounds
like a a mesh network rss style feed
they could be like we didn't publish
this it's on his server not on ours
it's all we do is aggregate links you
can view it for you can portal into it
from ours but
it's on their server exactly we didn't
publish this we're just
you know showing other people are
posting right so that that
that might be a good thing actually and
then people would still have to sue you
but it would strip away the powers of
these big corporations mm-hmm so that
could be a theoretical you could have
your own ads that way
um and building an ads an ad integration
thing would be key to making that
function
gregory horton says stephen crowder has
mug club blaze tv
ben shapiro has daily wire alex jones's
infowars you have
scnr don't fear the 230 repeal
i think if they repeal 230 they're going
to let me keep doing my thing because
they like me
as a what's the right word tepid milk
toast fences
you give them retention time but but
yes combined with the fact that i don't
swear i don't insult i for the most part
don't insult people i sometimes
i think we did a couple times on this
show like calm people morons but uh i
don't like
single out into individuals and say this
person is dumb in fact even when i'm
criticizing people on the left i usually
throw in a couple compliments
you know yeah like i did a video
recently about jenk yuger's op-ed where
he
was talking about the three different
rallies in america and i said he was
wrong
but he's got a few of these things right
so my respect you know because he did
make some good points
i won't make a video where i just attack
somebody and insult them i always try to
keep it you know that's why they like me
your
youtube guy is lawful good yes and
you're forced to talk about like chaotic
evil things but you do it from a lawful
good perspective so they're really happy
yeah it's just they it's it's hard to
argue why my content shouldn't be
allowed it's opinions people don't like
but i don't insult and target or
anything like that you know
daniel maxwell says section 230 needs to
be amended to require all companies
claiming their protections from it to
abide by court interpretations of first
member protections
and all laws regarding the first
amendment protections it's actually
simple
they need to change the phrase otherwise
objectionable into illegal that's it
case closed okay not really there's
probably a bunch of other nuance
but they have a provision that allows
them to moderate and remove content so
long as it's deemed
lewd lascivious filthy obscene or
otherwise objectionable
the otherwise objectionable part is
where they ban anyone and everyone
because they go well in my opinion
saying orange man good is offensive
because the orange med is in fact bad
misgendering
yeah misgendering right not
objectionable to any conservative
but to them it is so they ban it get rid
of otherwise objectionable to illegal
and then all of a sudden people can say
things like there are only two genders
or whatever
dan saw says hey tim just want to let
you know that the jerky will be sent
within the next
five or so days i've got to ask where i
forgot to ask before if there was
anything you or anyone was allergic to
emotionally so i know
i didn't realize you were sending us
jerky did not realize this either trent
lamolino says if you get nuked i'm done
with youtube
and i'll follow you and the gang
wherever i'll donate whatever whatever
needed that i can your crew is needed i
appreciate it
and i think the one thing we've really
we really need to step up on
uh i mentioned this before but there are
a lot of podcasts that are
not top podcasts we are a top pod guys
this is crazy
uh this show and my tim pool daily show
we have temple daily and tim cast irl on
itunes and stuff and these are top level
podcasts
not like number 10 or anything it's like
number 230 and like number 170 so it's
like it's still pretty good
but there are shows that are like ranked
500 or 1000 not even the top charts they
don't even register
and these people make millions of
dollars it's it's really simple
they just have proprietary websites
where they say come to our site
you pay x to to hang out and we give you
premium stuff that's something we don't
do you know our show relies just on like
the youtube system
and we probably should start producing
stuff directly for people who want and
like the content
so that's like that's what i just
started to do because i was so when i
got
demonetized on youtube all around i got
so scared that they were just going to
cut me off completely
what am i going to do i'm done so i i've
been working on like my own
individual app for just all my content
oh nice so i'm going to start promoting
that
um so this way like anything i want to
just post it there and i'm going to post
like all the uncensored versions so when
i want to talk about you know the
vaccines and stuff hey that's going to
be on the app
what's the app do you have a name for it
but you realize
you'll get banned for off site behavior
right that's a new thing they're adding
yeah i think i don't think you i don't
know if youtube does that yet but i know
twitch does that
but i was gonna patreon does that yeah
um
the app actually just came out today but
it's not like ready yet but i'm gonna
call it american now
news so this way i can grow it beyond me
right right you know because
you know when you know i want to bring
in new hosts new writers and stuff
all right man ed carone says the 10
million dollars to pakistani gender
studies is infuriating and all but what
about the 500 million to israel
first and foremost why are we giving any
money to anyone else when our country is
locked down
and in full-on panic mode that makes no
sense
but i will say you can justify military
aid to a place like israel
you can justify it i'm not saying it's
correct i'm saying there's a legitimate
argument and you'll argue with someone
there's no argument for 10 million
dollars to package any gender studies
i'm sorry
like that can wait okay it's crazy i
don't know what their gender studies
thing is you don't need the money
someone said we need them
i'll vote yes if you put this in and
then like four other people like yeah we
support that we'll all vote yes
why don't republican just put in donald
trump on the election yeah why not
nobody read it aoc was railing up
against how
long the bill was how they don't have
time to read it all it's all long
and then she votes in favor of it yeah
paul and ted cruz
are agreeing on a lot of points on that
bill ted cruz
ted cruz vita no aoc voted right yes and
that josh
republican also complained on twitter
and then voted for it anyway oh my god
yeah it was it was an excuse but people
need the
the money for the holidays you know
let's see
nicholas bowling show says 100 disagree
tim they are already unfairly banning
conservatives
230 doesn't protect us hey joey uh i
interviewed you for my site remember
nicholas bowling show i remember so uh
that's actually a good point
you know i guess conservatives who have
already been banned and can't have
channels are like
why would i care nuke the whole thing
well
you got to think outside yourself you
know there's a greater good
i you know i know that the argument is
if they can't be on it shut it down
because it's unfair
vengeance is a real feeling it's not
vengeance it's if you get rid of it
level the playing field i understand
yeah but the most powerful person tends
to dominate
a level playing field rational redneck
says what would the repeal of section
230 mean for sites like bit shoot
it would mean that [ __ ] shoot is
personally responsible for all content
posted on site because they would now be
treated like a newspaper making the
statement themselves
do they host the content or is it all
torrented between how does that
how does [ __ ] shoot funny well i think
it's torrented so maybe they would argue
we don't actually host it that's awesome
yeah
yeah maybe that would be fine mr
stantastic says ian don't get enough
credit lids is great as well
as you tim first super chat but i've had
a beer and need to listen to y'all later
thanks for what you do
what up don't forget joey salads while
we're at it
saladino lorenzo garcia says cnn
apparently just released trump's budget
demands and they're similar to the
original proposal
yeah i saw that i don't know a whole lot
about it but i think the issue is budget
demands are different from using the
covid stimulus as
a uh uh as a hostage like you know using
the american people's hostage basically
you have to vote for this otherwise the
people won't get their six hundred
dollars which they can't do anything
with because it's a pittance is it
taxable too
the success no probably not unemployment
insurance is taxed i told my girlfriend
yes
my girlfriend she never collected and
she's like unemployed because of
lockdown so she's gonna get a fat
check from all the backup from
california then from this
and i told her like you know since she
doesn't really need it like urgently
i i'm gonna help her like invest it to
like flip it
like you know i'm like investments have
been off popping off lately
i'm investing in all the all the
companies that support lockdowns i'm
investing all the companies that support
biden because those are the ones
yeah i'm invested in some military tech
this one super common i got this super
because of you this super chat oh really
yeah because i heard them talk about it
they're investing in china so yeah
oh you were saying well yeah yeah
investing in in what like
things that you think are going to go up
because of the current politics yeah
yeah so how are you talking about
corporate america pretty much taking
over like hey just fight
no talent here as much as we can i don't
want it to happen
as much as i don't want mcdonald's and
you know apple and amazon to take over
the world
like it's a way i can't do anything to
stop it so if it's gonna happen i might
as well ride the weight no
i disagree dude like pitching in all of
us
collectively we could well if you buy
stock in it you'll get some say
i was like maybe if everybody did you'd
be like shut it down i was like i want
to invest in people i i believe in who
do i invest in and i'm already in tesla
i was like i want to invest in tim but i
am with my energy
creating that idea like do you think
enough americans could come together
and buy enough shares and pool their
shares to actually like shut down a
company like
amazon i thought about doing that with
google i'm like maybe if i get enough
money one day i can just buy enough
shares of google to the point where i
tell them they have to remonetize my
page
so i think it's a hostile takeover it's
a tech they used to do that a lot
imagine if
like everybody bought one share of a big
company
and then collectively voted yeah you'd
have like a massive portion of this
company publicly controlled and they'd
have to the shareholders wanted
yeah maybe that's like a way to make
change you know yeah you start like a
collective firm
that does it yeah that's really cool mrt
fortune says with the steel tariffs
it doubled the price of materials for a
small manufacturing company i worked at
it seems similar to the minimum wage
debate this is interesting because i'm
talking to
a steel building company it's actually
not that expensive to get a big steel
building and we want to do it so that we
can have a place to film and
and have different sets and they told me
today
that they're like we can't give you a
quote right now because the price of
steel's about to go way up
because maybe we should just look into
graphene slider it can't build a
graphene building
you might be able to now it's lighter
than steel too you know what's
interesting we have these graphene
composite batteries
i bought for everybody because like ian
you talk about graphene all the time so
i was like christmas is coming up and i
looked up graphene products and they
have these batteries
this is crazy stuff dude they hold like
two and a half cell phone charges and
they charge in about 15 minutes
wow you can so like let's say you forget
to charge your phone you're like oh man
you take the battery you plug it in 50
minutes later you grab it walk out the
door and it's got two full charges in it
that's not
nuts it's crazy that's fast that's
graphene dude so
that's where we're at so far i tried
looking up how the battery works and
it's like too new i guess
it's a super capacitor and uh
um a super it's a it's a conductor and a
capacitor so it can
send current and store current so it's
like a battery and
uh yeah wire at the same time
pm says they hate us cause they ain't us
marissa says thanks to him i meant to
give ten dollars so i'm adding this to
the other super chat
i hate the dems love staten island there
you go shout out staten island love
staten island
charlotte gerd or jared says my daughter
applied to mcdees for her first job
they told her she will start at 10 an
hour for the first three months after
that her pay will be performance-based
that's their loophole to get
to get out of ten dollars an hour really
but they're paying your ten dollars an
hour
let's see daniel j coraca says long
island for statehood i2m sick of my
taxes going to new york city
would long island be republican yeah
do you think so the all of long island
i'm pretty sure voted republican
besides like maybe one part the hamptons
is that republican
seems like a lot of rich democrats you
can definitely pull up the map i'm
pretty sure it was like all red when i
looked at the map that's including
brooklyn and queens uh that part was
blue yeah but
they didn't outweigh the rest um
i'm sure that population probably does
outweigh long island that's the problem
the problem with staten island staten
island is a very
small borough of population wife
comparatively so we don't have we have
no
say basically in the mayor like zero say
neon light says i currently live in new
york and it's getting insane here
so far i live around the finger lakes
yet every rural area around me is forced
to live by ny city rules
nyc should not be a part of upstate and
that's what i remember you saying in one
of your episodes which i agree with and
i've been saying forever
it's that you know you've got the rural
areas and and you know
you know like new york city has all the
voting power and then you go to some
other area and that they
operate completely differently but now
they're forced to follow those rules
think about how insane it is look i get
it
if a city like baltimore was like we got
a problem with guns so we're gonna have
some strict laws
and now having those laws apply to
people who live in western maryland who
live in the middle of the woods and what
happens when 30 to 50 feral hogs are
come crashing on your property but the
state doesn't allow you have guns
because what's happening in baltimore
yeah these kind of things don't make
sense it doesn't make sense
we got to break up new york into a
couple days
break up the country la's got multiple
governors for their borough
areas like the different counties i
don't mean to different countries but i
mean different areas broken up into the
beverly hills has like their
their own thing i don't think they have
a mayor but they like they don't follow
la like they kind of do their own thing
different counties have different la
county and then there's a bunch of
counties within los angeles
these cities should be these big cities
should be separated from the states
they're in
yeah watch the rules change overnight
illinois becomes a red state
we wouldn't let it happen because
everybody would leave the cities like we
gotta get they'd live in the red areas
and work in the blue areas
there's no reason for one guy to have
the power de blasio's got
yep it's just too many people 18 million
people well no the issue is he doesn't
have the power people just give it to
him he's just given ridiculous
he's not given the power to do this the
cops just obey him because they don't
know what else that they want because
their money no no it's because the
officers that obey the unconstitutional
orders of de blasio are obsessed with
suckling his teats
so they they they love they hate each
other at the same time
no no no no the officers that follow the
unconstitutional edicts like when when
de blasio painted black lives matter
illegally in the street
those cops that went down to guard it
are just in love with de blasio they're
just doing it
and they they love licking his feet no
arrested de blasio for
vandalism right then and there well he
stole taxpayer money to do it and then
27 cops came out and they're doing a
pandemic during everyone has to wear a
mask
27 nypd cops were like the smart thing
for me to do is to obey this man right
instead of saying oh my god that are you
nuts it's like we
we did we bent over back you know why
you know what yep so this is how the
important point you brought up is that
the the cops who are screwing with this
bar there was nypd there
but now de blasio's like i'm going to
bring in the sheriffs because the mip
doesn't want to do it
and i i am not saying all cops i'm
saying clearly there are cops in big
cities
run by democrats who don't care and you
know why it's really obvious everybody
lost their jobs honestly the nypd should
arrest the sheriffs for violating the
constitution but listen listen
just do it you have you have people in
cops in new york
and they're going around seeing everyone
destitute
like suffering and losing their money
and they're like i have a job at least
i'm safe yeah and then and then
de blasio's basically like i want you to
oppress people and destroy their lives
and the cop goes better them than me
mm-hmm and so they just give him now put
on this white armor
now about exactly how a lot of i don't
want to say the
n word not the bad n word but the german
n word
uh german n word yes national socialist
yes
storm trooper that's the word i like
going to check your video
but i mean there was a lot of nazis that
were just doing it just because they
don't want to be on the other end they
were
i i read that there were jewish nazis
like jewish guards who are like if they
find out so i'll just go along with it
because they were scared yeah
dude and you know what people have been
telling me that because i made a post
on my personal facebook because i talked
to my you know just my staten island
friends and i would say it was like
dear law enforcement we bent over back
for you please do not enforce these
orders and they're
and some people are like oh they just
they're just following orders it's not
their fault i'm like that's even worse
that's even worse i'm like they took an
oath to hold the constitution we're the
ones paying them we're the ones that
defended them you know i want to see de
blasio and cuomo
only have the power that they are given
by i guess
by the police no no no by the police
it's that michael males says on the show
that all of these illegal acts all of
these unconstitutional laws
are letters to santa without the men and
women in uniform willing to enforce
against the against the constitution
yeah you know i'd love to see
nypd walking up to these sheriffs at
that bar max's or whatever
and just taking the like three ny nypd
guys grab the sheriff and
trans behind your back you're under
arrest what needs to happen you don't
live here we live here
these cops live in staten island why
would they let them come to their home
i'll tell you this man could you imagine
these these nypd cops who are either
sitting back and doing nothing
or enforcing this imagine if that was
the caliber of young man we had during
world war
ii they'd be like they'd land on the
beach of normandy and be like look man
you know
i'm just gonna side with the people who
are here because they're the ones in
power i'm not gonna fight to free people
well we need people to stand up and say
i live here get the
out of my home what we need to do is
publicly
i guess privately fund the good officers
yeah because if they're worried about
their jobs
but yeah if they're worried about losing
their job and getting their pay cut it's
like hey you know
we'll we'll let's all build up this
[ __ ] enough if you're worried about
three if you lose your pension if you
lose this let's take it out of this fund
like you're good you're securing
you're creating a new police department
creating a charity fund
we could do a global charity creating
our own government here's what i'm
advocating for is i'm saying
the police should arrest criminals yep
does that sound does that sound crazy
well if it's a bad law yeah you don't
want them arresting people that are
that are defined i didn't say people
defined i said criminals
crime doesn't make you bad like if it's
a bad law you want to become a criminal
to to fight against them
you're misunderstanding i didn't say
cops should arrest people who break the
law
i said cops should arrest criminals if
you say everyone has to go out and punch
people and i say i'm not going to do it
then i become a criminal on that you're
reading too much into it for no reason
i'm saying that what i'm saying is when
the sheriff shows up
and illegally detains someone that's
called kidnapping
and they have no constitutional
authority or statutory authority to do
it just because de blasio said so
it is then incumbent upon nypd to say
you are under arrest
for kidnapping for some crime yeah
i think i think they should uphold that
kind of crime that's literal crime it's
like moral says they can't do it and
they're doing it anyway they need to be
arrested but if you make a
law that says that you can't do
something you need to do then you have
to become a criminal
we're not talking about made up you just
said police should go arrest criminals
we're not talking about some new law
that was just made because de blasio
didn't pass any laws i'm just saying
crime isn't that
benchmark of whether or not you should
be destroyed i get what both of you guys
are saying
because you're you're saying that
criminality is based on
the laws that were made right yes you
know so like being a criminal
is defined by the law but i get what
you're saying at the same exact time
where de blasio and these sheriffs are
also breaking
the law the police should go and arrest
criminals yeah and i agree and you're
both right at the same time well they
should arrest those criminals
for that not all criminals what why not
because some laws are bad and those
people shouldn't be criminals how about
this constitutional
law i mean i don't think non-violent
drug offenders should be arrested
personally
not marijuana i mean you know just
because you say marijuana is illegal
doesn't mean that you should go arrest
them all it's a bad launch
it is a bad law they should be arrested
they should sue and the law should be
open but it destroys people's lives to
get arrested and waste their time and it
puts a mark on i think having an
argument about what you think is morally
correct is not the point the point is
the sheriff's are coming in and breaking
the law i think there's a statutory law
being broken by these sheriffs and by
some nypd
and their spineless pathetic and
terrified whiny baby cops who won't do
anything about that i agree
but it's dangerous to say cops should
arrest anyone that's breaking the law
that's cops should arrest people because
some laws are not
right so we've got to be careful about
what's encouraging for
yeah but you don't want to go disrupt
everybody then you go to a democrat
court and they lock you up for life bro
you can't you can't argue that some cops
have the discretion not to arrest people
breaking the law because then you're
gonna have a cop who who helps and
protects his friends
the law has to be upheld we're a nation
of laws if laws are not enforced then
what
i'm getting this because i told him he's
lawful good okay you're neutral good
it's a dungeons dragons thing think
about all the democrats who are like we
should we should decriminalize border
crossings
they shouldn't arrest these people they
broke no they did they literally
committed a crime
and just because you don't agree doesn't
mean i have to live by your rules
if we vote for people and laws are
passed we deal with ramifications of it
if eventually we find out the laws are
bad we change those
marijuana is now slowly being legalized
as people start to realize and yes
trump should pardon non-violent drug
offenders those who are literally
nonviolent not anybody who pled down
pleaded down the point is in new york
city when an nypd cop or a sheriff
breaks the law they need to be or
they'll be able to uphold their
their constitutional oath no they get
fired for that that's not a crime
i mean who's going to fire them the
mayor's not going to fire well and who's
going to arrest the cops committing
crimes
should be the good cause i don't care
who you are you get arrested
okay and that includes activists who are
protesting peaceful and safe all the
time
non-violent disobedience is the best
most effective way
to get change it works we've seen it
work at work with civil rights
and riots sour people to your cause but
you get arrested
and you deal with the results of
challenging the system there is a there
is a cost
to challenging the system so should the
fbi be the ones that are arresting cops
that are violating the constitution
the fbi doesn't do that that's a fbi
handles federal
i saw a video online of a cop arrested
and another cop yeah
so yeah right then and there like i
think maybe the cop was doing a little
too much like hitting the guy i don't
know yeah i just saw the quick clip
they immediately like took them and they
arrested were they both on duty
yeah they're both on duty cops and i
think they might have been working the
same exact thing let me put it this way
if i'm in new york and some guy walks up
to me
and grabs me and throws me to the ground
and pins my arm behind my back
for no reason that's assault and battery
so a cop should come and arrest that
person i don't care what they're wearing
i don't care if they're wearing a badge
now the issue with a cop arresting you
is different because
we as a community bestow authority upon
people under the
the ideal that they're going to be
stopping criminals
now a lot of police forces have
citations and fines and and quota
systems and that's all that's all bunk
bs for sure we can argue that
but if if i am doing everything legally
and i'm running my business and some
random guy comes in
and blocks the door and won't let
anybody in or takes my customers
and like detains them kidnaps them takes
them in their car
you gotta arrest that person could you
imagine if someone went to your business
and then just like grabbed the clerk and
threw him in a car and drove off you'd
be like whoa
under no statutory or constitutional
authority did that person do that i
don't care if they're wrong
here's another takeaway from everything
going on right now
where there's no constitutional
enforcement from the federal government
to the states
trump can invoke the insurrection act
because of this yeah he should have done
this six months specifically in the
insurrection act it says
if people's constitutional rights are
being deprived he can send in the
military to protect their rights i think
he should
i mean he's not running for reelection i
was hoping that trump was going to win
and then immediately do the insurrection
act and arrest cuomo
or s de blasio doesn't even need to
arrest him he could send in the military
to new york and reinstate
people's lives that's what needs that he
should just do that right now
just political willpower yeah trump
could do it
yeah that's what america needs right now
you know it's funny because people are
calling for trump to invoke martial law
and you've got like his most ardent
supporters and the left is saying
you know he can't do that or whatever
we're already under martial law
it's it's not martial law means military
law so not literally but we are under
totali
the democrats under there's listen
there's constitutional authority
and there's statutory law statutory law
are things that are passed by a
legislative body
constitutional authority is based on
what the constitution of your state or
your or the federal government gives you
under neither of these cuomo wolfe
newsome whitmer have done things they're
not allowed to do
and the supreme court has said of the
united states you can't do that you know
they do
okay this executive order has been
destroyed by the supreme court i'll
issue the exact same one now
literally the exact same like they'll
change some words or use some uh
alternate arguments to do these sounds
it sounds dictatorial despotic psychotic
and in violation of law and trump could
invoke the insurrection act because they
keep doing it the one thing i learned
from all of this
there's a reason why we have the
constitution and there's a reason why
the founding fathers
put the number two in there i don't like
to say it i don't like to think
i don't want it that's that's you but
you don't bring it up trump's the
president
yes but the problem the problem isn't
what the people are doing right now they
elected trump they elected trump to
solve these problems
and the people who are seizing who are
stomping on the rights of individuals
could be stopped by the president right
now they can also be stopped by us
that's a whole other conversation i
don't want like that to happen but it
just seems like
that would be at right now this point in
time there seems to be nothing happening
from the federal government or from
trump
and that i mean yeah it's going to be up
to us they're destroying
economics they're not like stealing
people's children
if the cops are coming in and taking
people's kids in the middle of the night
you'd probably see people
enforcing their their second amendment
and i don't know i don't think so
you don't the james younger kids we're
supposed to preach this younger case
a man's son has been essentially taken
from him
and the courts ruled that the child will
undergo gender uh reassignment therapy
if a father wouldn't rise up in defiance
of the government after his son was
taken in that way
then i really don't see the politics
that's slow heating up
republicans where way we're way more
peaceful than the left if we're
if we were as violent as left none of
this would be happening that's a scary
thing yeah
and you know the lockdown protest
against whitmer from months ago
tens of thousands of americans show up
peacefully with guns and what happened
she extended the lockdowns
that was it then they went home it's
like oh because republicans we want to
do everything legally in the courts
republicans want to be left alone yeah
we just want to be left alone
i appeal to the president donald please
enforce you think he should invoke the
interaction i think you should protect
our economy at all costs from these
things especially
great things are going right now if
you're not going to win the election
what do you got to lose
it's kind of crazy that it's it's a slow
boil we're frogs in a pot
the economy is destroyed these these
leftists
have no idea how debt to gdp works how
money printing works
how modern monetary policy works
anything like this
and they advocate for things that make
no sense like deficit spending to pay
for health care it's like all you're
doing is stripping away the savings of
people
like it makes it so that nobody should
save anything ever but then of course
they use that and say we have no savings
we should have government you know
mandated
spending you know and and buying of the
resources you need
with these democrat states destroying
the economy we get the 600
coven package that that 900 billion
deal attached to a 2.3 a total of 2.3
billion dollars
uh omnibus spending for ridiculous
things like pakistani gender studies
shows you
the system is corrupt and trump isn't
fixing it
that's it trump trump apparently
submitted a budget request that was
similar to the omnibus so people are
mentioning in the super chat
whether it's true or not what does trump
come out and do what does trump come on
do
he says triple it trump didn't say
reopen the economy now i will not sign
this relief bill until there's a mandate
for the states to rip their economies
and protect small businesses throw more
money at it exactly he said triple a
democrats who they said
they said great much obliged yeah
absolutely trump
it's kind of a being a republican in one
way is kind of a double-edged sword
versus being a democrat
and the democrats worldview of fixing it
they can just come in and like what the
dictators are doing these governors
oh i want this done up here's an order
blink it's done
even though it's unconstitutional it's
tyrannical it's illegal with republicans
on the other hand if they want to fix
something
we don't act like for the most part we
don't act like dictators
to get something done and fix it we
don't have to go this process that
process and this push back and that then
you got to play the game and do all this
whereas if it was a democrat here's a
bill sign it tyrannical done
right legislating what you want i think
about that with gun control like
just saying it's illegal all of a sudden
while people are at home printing their
guns like you can't enforce that law
look like a mockery donald trump vetoed
the ndaa
in it is a as an amendment that would
take away his ability to win
it would curtail his ability to invoke
the insurrection act he would require
the secretary of defense
and himself to sign off and provide
reasonable certification to congress to
approve otherwise he would not be able
to invoke the insurrection act
so if so think about it this way one of
the provisions of the insurrection act
is to enforce the constitutional rights
of the citizens of the state
new york is in violation of that
numerous times blocking people from
going to churches and things
you know and and things of that nature
california is shutting los angeles is
shutting off people's water and
electricity
for for exercising their first amendment
right
mitch mcconnell on the 29th is going to
convene the senate
to override trump's veto when that
happens
trump will lose the ability to invoke
the insurrection act
if trump would do it he has five more
days
that's it four more days probably to do
it before they
they override his veto who do you have
to send in the national guard military
or national guard federalized national
guard or the military
i worry that if this sets a precedent
and that gets done and what if biden
comes in and wants to ban guns
nationwide no the second amendment that
would be in defiance of
the constitution but so i mean what
we're seeing is these these
police officers don't care but with the
military
the military i don't think would well i
feel we'll see you know like yeah
i never thought in i never thought i
would see
law enforcement yeah arrest people for
nothing i never did
right before lockdown started i talked i
i did an interview with
um an nypd officer and i was telling him
about the whole lockdowns i'm like i was
saying there's no way in hell
that this will ever be enforced and this
is before all this happened and he said
to me
you'll be surprised i did not believe
him i refuse to believe him
and then a month later i've been to
enough countries i've been to enough
protests
and i've seen enough action from police
to know that many of these people just
don't care now i don't think all cops
are bad that you know the left uses a
worse word than that and 1312 or
whatever
acab i think there are a lot of bad cops
and i think we need police reform yep
and i think there are a lot of good cops
and they tend to be smaller cities they
tend to be more rural
and they tend to be conservative and
they know it's the big city cops
who will you know you over the head and
say i don't care you're right we need to
fund them
the people that are violating the orders
because if they lose their job
that's it you know for them but if we
have a charity that making sure they're
going to get paid regardless then
there's incentive to do the right thing
you should start it tim you've got no i
don't know about that
hire someone to start it you know people
get mad at me because they think i'm
i'm going to be some like a leader i'll
start it and then i'll pay you to
promote it not a sponsorship people
people
people like trump supporters are mad
saying like everyone's got to be on the
front lines of this fight and going out
showing up on dc and the six and i'm
like i'm i'm
i might i might go to i don't know we
got tired of all these lockdown protests
now
this was like the sixth the six isn't a
lockdown protest the sixth
is the overturning the election for
trump protest
so they're saying everyone has to go
there and i'm like bro i'm not a leader
i'm not a part of your tribe i'm a due
to complaints on the internet and i will
always be there
and i'm not going to rally or rabble or
tell anybody what they should or
shouldn't do
i'll tell you what i think what i want
to happen and you do your thing you make
your own opinions his uh drone war
and escalation and his lack of
leadership on assange has really kind of
soured me to donald
what's his lack of leadership on assange
he's just not doing anything about it he
keeps saying like um
i'm considering that was like last week
and now this week he's announced he's
still
he's considering it again he instructed
the ecuadorian embassy
the right and the ecuadorian embassy
that's that's leadership not not what we
want
not the right leadership right so he
certainly made a decision
paul assange out of the embassy and now
we've yet to see him pardon the second
talk about pardoning the guy
like daniel ellsberg he revealed the war
atrocities julian assange didn't commit
any crime
he's just being effectively detained
for a decade nearly it's like eight
years now
and now he's facing charges because they
just don't like that he's effective
he exposed the intelligence agencies
and some of the messed up stuff the us
was doing and it really helped trump
it it showed a lot of trump supporters
exactly what they were doing and why
you know a lot of these arguments
against them uh against like deep state
you know
people were were correct and for a long
time like a good example is sarah palin
she spoke out against wikileaks
wikileaks published her emails sarah
palin just came out defending assange
because what we got out of wikileaks was
good and then you realize
you're gonna get with wikileaks you're
gonna get stuff that probably don't like
you don't want leaked
and you're gonna get stuff they're
probably grateful was leaked we learn
these things from people like assange
but assange isn't even the leaker or the
whistleblower
he's the publisher he's the journalist
and they and they're doing this to him
trump needs to to pardon that guy asap
the concern is
if trump pardons him right now the uk
will find an excuse to keep him
and that trump his best bet would be to
get assange to the us before pardoning
him
how i don't think it's possible it's
like a secret raid to get him out of
there he already did that
what did he say he raided the ecuadorian
embassy and arrested assange and now
that the british authorities have him
but i mean a raid on the british
authorities
no they're trying to extradite him but
he has the legal right to block that
tradition
and they don't trust the us government
so they're not going to allow it
so i think trump should just pardon him
i don't think there's any point in
waiting and if
sanji wants to stay in the uk doesn't
want to come here then just pardon him
and be done with it whatever
now how do we deal with the the fact
that people have their rights completely
stomped on in a bunch of these states i
don't know
because do we just sit back as the water
slowly boils and we sit in and we know
for a fact because of supreme court
rulings in like
several states already they are actively
violating constitutional rights of these
people
or do we say something must be done and
trump should invoke the insurrection act
and you know
hypothetically go in and then enforce
constitutionality i thought he should
have done it on day two of the riots
but it's like the riots and then there's
the shutdown and it's
like they're two different psychological
listen the the insurrection act has been
invoked
numerous times like couple dozen times
and
the most recent was for riots 1992 la
riots
then you also had the baltimore riots
then you had the chicago riots in 1968
these were nowhere near as crazy as what
we see because of the insurrection act
probably well i'm sorry actually the l.a
riots were pretty
nuts but i think nationwide riots and
then a hundred days in the pacific
northwest
trump didn't do it there were like five
days where they were just watching and
then
no one responded federally so then
there's all these other riots started
breaking out you know why it probably
didn't really happen
over the summer and that stuff because i
it's all politics at that point it's
like what move will help him win
reelection will letting them destroy
themselves he doesn't have to worry
about that right now now he doesn't need
to worry or but
at the end of the day we also don't know
what's going on behind the scenes with
this election stuff maybe he knows some
stuff
that we don't know that maybe he knows
i'm going to win this
week i like that and the i like this the
super chat i gotta read it
monty m says ian pay your college loans
then talk about cops
i was a cop for 13 years the nypd is a
bunch of punks
well right now my loans are on a
temporary deferment because of covid but
uh
it's my you know probably number three
concern with debts
i pay off my credit credit card debts
and my taxes first and then
i am i am panda says i agree with joey
salads everyone here put money where
mouth is and show up in
on jan 6th in dc that's the big question
trump won't make a move unless he knows
he has popular support
if people don't show up on the six i'll
tell you this if 10 million people show
up in dc on the six and it's just
endless field waves trump will do
whatever trump will be like
okay i think i'm gonna go because i my
flight is on the sixth i might just
reschedule it
so i can get there go to dc yeah i'm
hearing from people that aren't super
political tell me they're going
yeah so i i don't know that's the thing
is people who aren't political or forced
into being political because of the
lockdowns like
a normal business owner a normal worker
that doesn't care about politics i just
want to live my life they want trump to
win now
yeah now you're thrusted into it where
when uh you know a black lives matter
throws a a you know
a garbage can through your window now
you're now you're in the political game
it's a dc is a great city to congregate
into there's all this wide open space
and like
plazas and roads to shut down easy to
shut down roads cool landmarks oh
interesting uh jon stewart says the
provision curtailing the insurrection
act was only in the earlier hr bill not
the final senate draft that he voted
vetoed
interesting i thought it was in the it
was at it as an amendment as an
amendment
that was uh there was a fact check on it
that said it was included in the bill
but i guess you know they took it off
took it off
anyway i'll i'll say it again if i think
if you had 10 million people in dc i
think trump would invoke the interaction
act he'd overturn
elections he'd just do whatever he wants
because he has the people right there
he would literally just be like say
something you know what i mean the
people are here they support me i'm
going to do it and they would cheer for
it
but if people don't show up trump's just
going to be like thanks everybody have a
nice day
mm-hmm trump like in any political move
won't do anything unless they feel like
they have the interest
obama was the same way he didn't have
any support so he just capitulated
yeah all right let's see uh let's do it
let's just do uh one more
josh branson says the military has
already gone door to door for guns
before
look at post katrina new orleans
interesting
well then if you haven't already smash
the like button thanks for hanging out
on this christmas eve eve show
we are off tomorrow and for christmas
and then we'll be we'll be back monday
and i'll be doing my show next on
saturday so check out my other channels
at youtube.comtimcast and
youtube.comcastnews you can follow me on
twitter
instagram parlor at tim cast joey do you
have anything you want to mention your
twitter um my twitter oh yeah that's
right
your your instagram um i guess i guess
like my podcast yes the joey saladino
show
or the app america now news you got any
merchandise
i got them wearing cancelled we're where
can we buy those where can people get
merch lincolnbio.com very cool
oh that's awesome and your youtube
channel is pretty huge right it's just
not monetization it's a big i haven't
posted in like six months because it's
demonetized
so youtube reps if you're watching just
just throw me a phone
yeah man get this guy back on the market
yeah i have a whole catalog of content
i'm ready to post that i was filming i
was like
joey salads 2.0 i'm going to come in
hard i got highly produced content and
i'm right about to post it can't you do
sponsors though
uh my viewership plummeted after the
amount of time
that's the way it works that's what i'm
saying my the sponsorships don't really
pay me much because it's hard for me to
decide my price because my
my viewership fluctuation it's like i'll
get 50 000 views on a video 2 million on
this one so it's like how do i charge
them right
do you have a minds account no we i
co-founded that with bill you should get
started on there because i know bill
loves your work
yeah he's the ceo i think he'd push your
stuff right yeah definitely definitely
mines
yeah i'll check that out because they
actually have a pro partner program now
too
okay it's not as good as youtube but
it's at least it's something
because you know with all due respect to
say like uh bit shoot
mine's actually you get paid like part
of program that's the
key but it's not as good as facebook or
youtube but it's the only way to make it
happen
i've been just distributing my content
on like all the old platforms
you know it's like a little bit here a
little bit there but it adds up you know
it's something significant
doing um this new technology where they
can you can link it with your youtube
channel so any new
youtube uploads will upload to mines
automatically cool i'm gonna check that
it's a free software which is nice and i
think that was
something else i was going to say about
mines i don't know are you going to
mention your minds oh i have a minds
channel at ian crossland along with all
my other social media accounts at ian
crossland
throughout the internet right on and of
course you can follow at sour patch lids
yeah i am on twitter pushing all the
buttons yep l-i-d-s posing spicy memes
correct and uh we're we're back monday
right um
yeah maybe well i don't have anyone
lined up yet oh well we're super excited
for the
like the second week of uh january is
going to be it's
getting yeah it's awesome i'll just put
it this way there are people who are in
congress who are planning on
you know their names but i'm not gonna i
think i know i don't announce guests
because then when they cancel everyone's
disappointed not if
but when because they do well especially
people who are really
busy and people like am i allowed to say
my guess or would that like give it away
no i don't say anything yeah just in
case you know congress is a verb
it means to move together yeah ian let
me ask you a question
what is uh in is what is uh
pro and khan in that context what does
pro mean
forward what does khan mean against
what is progress to move forward what is
congress
to move against boom that's their job
say no to the president when he gets
crazy it's true
all right everybody thanks for hanging
out merry christmas happy new year we'll
be back
uh at some point and uh we'll see you
then thanks for hanging out bye
you